hey
hi
welcome to the food boys season one
marathon where we compared some of the
biggest differences in uk and us fast
food we've compiled every episode from
season one into one convenient bundle
for your viewing pleasure but stick
around for some behind the scenes info
from myself and from joe to show you how
we brought the show to life
[Music]
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out the biggest
differences between uk and u.s
mcdonald's
so the mcdonald's episode is where food
wars all began uh joe did you have any
problems filming this episode yeah i had
to go back and forth mcdonald's three
times to get everything and they still
didn't have the mcnuggets boxes that we
wanted
this is what a small drink looks like in
the uk this
is a u.s small this is what a medium
drink looks like this
is a u.s medium and this is a lodge
oh and this
is a u.s large
so with our mcnuggets in the uk
the default adult sizes on the menu
are a box of six
a box of nine or a share box of 20.
nuggets
you can get a box of four
or you can get a six piece or
ten
twenty for sharing or
ah
40.
and according to the three mcdonald's in
the area they don't have 20 or 40 boxes
they just do them in increments of 10.
but this is on the menu
in the uk we've got three sizes of fries
these are our small fries in the paper
bag here is the small fry these are our
medium fries and the iconic cotton
here is the medium fry and then these
are our large fries and here
is the large fry
so we can find an exact weight
measurement for this rise online so what
we're going to do is wear them ourselves
just out of curiosity i'm gonna bring
our trusty friend the scales back and
we're gonna weigh the big mac and see if
there is any difference in size i'm not
sure there will be but let's find out
hang on
so while mcdonald's fries might look and
taste pretty similar in the uk and the
us in the uk we only have three
ingredients which is oil salt and
potatoes
the mcdonald's french fries in america
have way more ingredients these fries
are made from potatoes obviously a
vegetable oil which has canola oil corn
oil soybean oil hydrogen
hydrogenated
genotated
thank you hydrogenated soybean oil
natural beef flavor dextrose sodium acid
phosphatate fascistic
fast
pyrophosphate pyrophosphate
sodium acid pyrophosphate which is used
to maintain the color uh are they that
much of a different color than the ones
in the uk is it worth it can we get a
side-by-side comparison or that much
more bright yellow we need to put sodium
acid pyrophosphate or whatever it's
called in it
salts and i should mention that a
natural beef flavor contains hydrolyzed
wheat and hydrolyzed milk as a starting
ingredient
and of course i have no idea what that
means so the biggest calorie difference
in a big mac actually comes from the
source in the us they've got about 40
more calories than we do in the uk we're
not sure if this is because there's more
source or because of the ingredients
list in the uk it's just a little bit
more simple
our sauce is made of soybean oil sweet
relish which is made of diced pickles
sugar high fructose corn syrup distilled
vinegar salt corn syrup all right two
types of corn syrup xanthan gum
calcium chloride spice extractives water
and i've heard of that egg yolks
distilled vinegar spices onion powder
salt propylene glycol alginate garlic
powder vegetable protein which has
hydrolyzed corn soy and wheat sugar
columnar color turmeric extractives of
paprika and of course
soy
lachapen
leachate
like a pen
i don't know which one it is
so if you are trying to eat healthily at
mcdonald's it might actually be the
drinks that you have to look out for
that's nothing guys
our chocolate shake 840 calories
that's as many calories as two
cheeseburgers and one hamburger so what
does that all mean if you were to walk
into a uk mcdonald's and order yourself
a large big mac meal with a milkshake it
would be around 1400 calories and if you
were to get the large big mac meal with
the chocolate shake in america the total
here is
1870 calories so that's 1870 calories
the daily calorie allowance for an
american dude is 2500 okay so you have
630 left
one mcnugget is 55 calories right so you
could also have 11 more nuggets and
there you go that's all you need for the
day
here's everything you can only get at a
uk mcdonald's
so here we've got the veggie deluxe
burger which is a veggie burger that's
served with some mayo and some lettuce
here we've got a chicken legend
which is a chicken burger again served
with mayonnaise lettuce chicken legend i
don't even know what that is not going
to catch on that can stay in the uk
we have a range of wraps that you can
get in the uk we have a wrap of the day
here we've got the faith crisp which is
some chicken
along with some veg and some spicy beta
sauce here we've got some veggie dippers
these were actually introduced as part
of veganuary in 2020 in the uk but
they're stuck on the menu so these are
vegan society approved and they're sort
of like a fried bean patty sort of thing
like pick a more unappetizing thing to
get a mcdonald's
magic difference and then finally we've
got some mozzarella dippers which are
just kind of mozzarella sticks really
well
sucks to be in the uk because everything
you see right here is usa only baby
usa only
so i'm going to talk about the coffee
drinks real fast here in the u.s we have
all the same coffee drinks they do in
the uk but every coffee drink has an
iced
version and also a caramel
and or french vanilla and or mocha
version depending on what you're getting
so we in the u.s of course have more
variety
shamrocks shake the shamrock shake is
like it's like vanilla and mint shake
strawberry sundae
this has recently been discontinued in
the uk sorry guys still got in the u.s
my favorite as a kid
caramel sundae
fruit and yogurt parfait maybe it's
healthy i have no idea probably not
those were the cold items i wanted to
get out of the way as they slowly melt
under these lights got a lot more to go
through
harry bear with me here buddy
buttermilk crispy chicken sandwich yo i
think this was introduced when the
chicken sandwich was really heating up
when chick-fil-as are taking over let's
see what's under the hood
look at
that look at this
quarter ponder with cheese deluxe this
is your fancy quarter partner with
cheese this is uh for a sunday dinner
when you have company over ah so much
sausage breakfast burrito even after
it's for a while it's like still like
glowing
yellow
now these are the buttermilk
crispy
chicken tenders these smell amazing i
want to bite into so bad
i just take a big bite i want to talk
about sauces real quick okay i'm at
mcdonald's and i go give me one of
everything i've heard from the i've
heard from harry and the team over the
uk that some of these they don't have
including sweet and sour honey mustard
what else don't you guys have i don't
think you guys have ranch either or
buffalo i gotta say though the sauces
are everything we've got a couple of
sauces that are kind of unique to the uk
as well we've got a sweet curry dipping
sauce
and then we've also got a salsa dip as
well which i didn't know existed until
today
oh yes donut sticks these
donut sticks also come with the
chocolate dipping sauce another thing
i'm certain they don't have in the uk
yeah
breakfast is served
look at this oh yeah who's ready to
start the day
it's mcgriddle talk
so for those of you in the uk who don't
know what a mcgriddle is
the united states mcdonald's had this
genius idea what if we took breakfast
sandwiches replaced the buns and made
them pancakes and somehow injected some
sort of syrup flavor into the pancakes
and the mcgriddle was born and i have to
say they're fantastic this one right
here the bacon egg and cheese mcgriddle
this is the
sausage
[Music]
is the sausage egg and cheese
mcgriddle american food engineering at
its finest look at that
in the uk you guys call biscuits cookies
here no so in the uk
biscuits are cookies what we call
cookies in the u.s
uh biscuits are what we call
uh
i don't know what else you can call them
like
you bake them and they're from the south
and they're dry and i don't know what
they are much like the mcgriddles we
have a version of every breakfast
sandwich that instead of the regular bun
bread it's biscuits not the cookie
biscuits like you guys have um
these biscuits joe you were so close on
the whole cookie biscuit thing what you
guys call biscuits we would actually
kind of call scones or scones depending
on where you're from and the thought of
putting breakfast food in between them
is kind of weird they're usually
reserved for cream and jam for an
afternoon tea
last
and
in my opinion
least
is this thing
the
southwest
grilled
chicken
salad
but can i can i eat now
yeah yeah
i don't care how many calories it's just
really good
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out the difference
between a u.s and a uk kfc this is food
wars
i had kfc leftovers for days i ended up
giving some of it away to my neighbors
in my building yeah i was the same i
took like three buckets of chicken home
for myself and my roommates i even kind
of made a pot pie which you guys had on
the menu and we didn't sorry you made a
pot pie out of kfc leftovers
i just took the kfc chicken took the
skin off it put it in a pot for some
soup some vegetables and then a pastry
on top and it was pretty good
now you can't actually get a small drink
at a uk kfc it starts at regular
this is what a regular drink looks like
this is what a us regular looks like and
this is what a loud string looks like
and this
is what a us large looks like
this is a regular fries
and this
is a large price
here's the u.s regular right
you want to go the next size up
this
is the u.s large
look at how big that is it's like five
of those ones that he had
let's find out how much a large fries
weighs in the uk
let's weigh our large fry
oh man
they're packed in there dude look at
that is that everything
this is what a regular popcorn chicken
looks like
we have
a large popcorn chicken and this is what
a large popcorn chicken looks like and
if you want to go even larger than the
large get yourself a popcorn chicken
box
something for you and your buddies i'm
sure
not eating this by yourself
[Music]
did i lose any
no no way am i doing this without oh
don't jinx it
oh
yep
[Music]
in the uk you can get buckets in three
sizes you can get a six piece
you can get a 10 piece
or you can get a 14 piece
eight piece
whoa
12 piece
this is i'm not gonna i can't even dump
it
yo
look how much chicken this is
oh my god what a mess
[Music]
unfortunately kfc in the uk doesn't
disclose its ingredients but what we do
know is calories
for example in the uk
a drum
is 170 calories
and in the u.s
one of these guys for the original
recipe is 130 calories but if you get
extra crispy like this guy right here
it's actually 170. usa is actually still
winning on calories that's largely
thanks to the sides and the drinks if
you were to walk into a uk kfc and order
a three-piece meal and they gave you a
drum a thigh and a wing with a large
fries and a large pepsi that would come
to
1150 calories
our large fry is 930 calories and our
large drink is 380. and if you were to
order a three piece with a large fry and
a large drink in the u.s it would be
roughly this many calories
the kfc in the u.s has released its
ingredients list i would like to go over
the ingredients of the french fries at
the kfc in the u.s all right here we go
sea salt monosodium glutamate
maltodextrin salt dextrose vegetable
powders try calcium phosphate hydrolyzed
soy proteins spices soybean oil natural
flavors potassium chloride paprika
extract color turmeric extract color
potatoes obviously vegetable oil it has
soybean oil canola cotton seed and or
sunflower uh beached beached bleached
wheat flour and it contains two percent
or less of rice flour germ weed
somolia semolina samolet semolina durum
wheat
somolia samolina i don't know what that
word is it looks like it's easy but it's
hard to say semolina semolina dermweed
semolina there you go dextrin salt de
germed yellow corn meal oh thank god
it's been determined corn starch
leavings sodium acid pyrophosphate
sodium bicarbonate dextrose again
xanthan gum there is a natto extract
color the sodium dihydrox the sodium
dihydrogen
pyrophosphate in parentheses to maintain
color okay we add so many chemicals to
our fries we add more chemicals to make
it look like it doesn't have any
chemicals thank you
to sodium
dehydrate
dehydrator
yeah whatever
here are some things you can only find
on the menu at a uk kfc so instead of a
chicken sandwich what we call ours is
the chicken philip burger i think it's
pretty much the same thing it's like
breaded and fried chicken between two
buns with some lettuce and some
mayonnaise we also have something called
the zinger burger which is pretty much
the same thing but the spice level is
amped up a little bit you can also turn
these burgers into a tower burger what
that does is adds cheese and a hash
brown to the burger which in my opinion
very worthwhile addition we have some
stuff on our kfc they can't get in the
uk and surprisingly some things i
thought were like kind of
like paramount to the kfc menu mashed
potatoes and gravy this to me seems like
something that has just always
been part of kfc along with the chicken
look at his mashed potatoes man it's a
tub of mashed potatoes okay let's make a
mess oh yeah
oh my goodness put that on the cover of
gravy aficionado magazine
another thing i didn't realize you guys
don't have
biscuits or as you call them scones this
is called a famous bowl it is
mashed potatoes and gravy and corn
topped with popcorn chicken topped with
cheese all in one bowl uh yeah this
thing i don't think i've ever had one of
these because it looks
ridiculous
now joe i'm glad you also think that the
famous bowl doesn't look that great
because to me that looks like a
nightmare now we have a slightly
different approach to sides in the uk
compared to the us for example our corn
comes on the cob
baked beans these are slightly different
to the regular beans that you might put
on toast in the uk they have kind of a
barbecue sauce flavor to them there's a
few other language differences like
instead of chicken tenders we call ours
chicken mini fillets
mini fillets chicken tenders they look
exactly the same we got those
yes they have corn we have ours off the
cob which i think is
not as good as on the cob this pile
right here
and i know they do have wings at kfc in
the uk yes i know but only in the u.s
can you order them by 48
[Laughter]
48 wings
i'm dying right now man
you smell so good the pot pie
when i saw pot pie in the menu i was
like yeah a little side pot pie no dude
this thing
is like a puppy this thing has kind of
got some weight to it i gotta say the
pot pie actually looks quite good we
love meat pies here in the uk you'll
often see people tucking into like a
steak and kidney pie or a chicken pie
but yeah they should probably put that
on the menu over here i think they'd
cash in on the british market it's chalk
sauces it's sauce talk
sauce talk i think that these sauces are
also
specific only to the u.s and not the uk
the kfc finger looking good sauce
see that
we also have the summertime barbecue
sauce
uh honey mustard
and of course buttermilk ranch
there are a few sources which are
exclusive to the uk for example we have
this spicy supercharger dip which is
kind of like a spicy mayo type thing we
have some sweet chili sauce garlic
mayonnaise another really good option
garlic mayo on chips is just fantastic
why don't we have those sauces here
oh man i want those now usually we'd
have even more exclusive menu items to
show you but unfortunately uk kfc is
currently operating with a reduced menu
here's what you could normally find on
the menu at a uk kfc
[Music]
a vegan burger the big daddy burger
a range of chicken wraps
some rice boxes
onion rings
curry sauce
crush ems
and a full range of hot drinks including
english breakfast tea
at the uk you can get
teas
including
english breakfast tea now technically
you can't get tea
at the kfc's in the us but you can get
something called mountain dew sweet
lightning which i think
is probably pretty close
yeah that's pretty much exactly the same
as a breakfast tea
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between domino's pizza in the uk and the
us
this is food wars
this might actually have been my
favorite episode to shoot what about you
joe i love shooting this episode i just
thought some of the visuals were really
cool particularly the bird's eye view we
actually had our camera person charlie
shooting that one and he was just
standing on a table getting some stuff
by hand it wasn't the most professional
setup but i think it got the job done
this was also the first usa only
exclusive and arguably the worst i could
give a ted talk on how much i hate
banana peppers
this is the smallest pizza you can get
in the uk it's called an individual and
it measures seven inches across
our smallest is believe it or not the
small here it is and it measures in
diameter 10 inches
the next size up is a small
which measures 9.5 inches
next size up for the us is our medium
which is 12 inches
this is 11.5 inches
well i'm starving
hey
i grabbed the slice
i'm starving this pizza smells so good
let's get breakfast
next pizza next up for the us is our
large which is a 14 inch diameter
oh hell yeah
what's with the way they cut your large
pizza harry it's ridiculous look at that
and not to be outdone the u.s has one
more size the extra large diameter 16
inches bro
look at the size of this thing
now a 2.5 inch difference might not
sound like a lot but if you factor that
into the surface area it's actually 58
square inches wider than the uk's
largest pizza which is almost a third of
an increase
am i looking at this right is it
supposed to be six slices it's six
slices that can't be right six slices
for a extra-large pizza
look at the size of these slices
in the u.s at a domino's the extra-large
pizza will cost you a very reasonable
13.99
that
is
201 square inches which breaks down to
roughly seven cents an inch
nice
now shockingly 13.99 will only get you a
small pizza in the uk
a small pizza is 9.5 inches across and
that gives it a surface area of 71
square inches now if you divide the
13.69 price tag by the 71 you find out
that you're actually paying 19 cents per
square inch
ultimately it means that if you went
into a us and uk dominoes with 13.99 to
spend you'd be able to get more than
double the pizza for your money in the
us store
let's compare large cheese pizzas in the
two countries
this is what a uk large cheese looks
like
and this is what a large properly cut
domino's cheese pizza looks like in the
u.s
it's cut into 10 pieces and each slice
contains 176 calories that means that in
total the pizza in the uk is
1760 calories instead of 10 we got 8
slices that means each slice is roughly
280 calories which makes the whole pizza
2
240 calories and according to the thing
that was written for me that is almost
480 calories more than the uk large but
why is that exactly
let's see if we can get any clues from
the ingredients
let's start with the foundation of any
pizza which is the dough in the uk the
dough is made of wheat flour a wheat and
milk pre-mix rapeseed oil water and
yeast
yes but here in the u.s our dough is
made
of enriched flour we oh god i hate
reading this stuff enriched flour which
is wheat flour iron thiamine mono
nitrate niacin riboflavin and folic acid
water soybean oil and it contains less
than two percent of the following sugar
salt whey
maltodextrin
dextrose dough conditioners such as
sodium sterile
laci
lactolate i don't know it's on the
screen you read it out loud enzymes
calcium sulfate absorbic acid calcium
phosphate l-cysteine good for hangovers
i hear yeast and cornmeal
uh yeah much different a lot more
chemicals
who saw their coming
how about the cheese domino's in the uk
refers to its cheese simply as
mozzarella and it's mostly because the
ingredients are just that
in the u.s domino's doesn't possibly
can't call their cheese mozzarella
instead they refer to it as
pizza cheese so the dominoes in the us's
pizza cheese has the following
ingredients
part skimmed mozzarella cheese okay
which is pasteurized milk cultures salt
enzymes modified food starch cellulose
cellulose
non-fat milk whey protein concentrate
natural flavors and sodium
proponent
prop
eonate propioni now let's look at the
pepperoni most of the ingredients in u.s
and uk pepperoni are actually pretty
similar they both contain pork salt
dextrose spices sodium nitrite citric
acid flavorings and starter culture
you know the only difference is that our
pepperoni contains beef
also preservatives butyhydrate
hydrolazines and buddha hotel and blah
blah bha and bht i can't pronounce them
they're bad
it turns out bha and bht are actually
subject to restrictions in the european
union and can't be added to foods such
as pepperoni this might be because
studies have shown that bha can cause
tumors in rats and is therefore
reasonably anticipated to be a
carcinogen in humans
[Music]
oh well
i'm gonna die doing what i love
eating banned chemicals
[Music]
we reached out to domino's to get some
clarity on the pepperoni situation we
got our info from their ingredients web
page however when we checked with them
they told us that their information was
incorrect and they've updated it since
to say that bha and bht have now been
removed from the pepperoni i think this
happened at some point during 2018 they
couldn't say exactly when but joe it
sounds like you're okay after all
[Music]
here are all the items you can only find
on the menu at a uk dominoes
and here are all the things you can only
get at a us dominoes let's start with
the pizza
itself so firstly it's the crust options
now in the uk we can actually get
stuffed crust but what we've gone for
here is the italian style crust
apologies to the country of italy for
this one now the italian crust is
basically the same dough but just
thinner and therefore a bit more crispy
there are a few toppings that you can
only get on your pizza in the uk these
include some options we've got here like
meatballs sweet corn and red onion but
that's not all you can also get things
like catalan chicken which is a chicken
and a kind of paprika spice you can get
tandoori chicken which is chicken with
some indian spice blends and you can
also get tuna on your pizza
whoa wait did he say tuna
tuna on a pizza
no
no way so this right here is a pizza
that has everything you can only get at
a us dominoes first of all the crust it
is our thin brooklyn style crust instead
of tomato sauce we did an alfredo white
sauce we got banana peppers on here
salami
feta cheese
and also parmesan and cheddar
this should be known as the u.s only
like pizza hut should have this on the
menu you go give me the u.s only and
this is the pizza they give you
[Music]
yuck
don't get this
[Laughter]
yeah i hate that
grab a slice see what you think so here
are some uk sides that you won't find on
the menu at a us dominoes first of all
we've got the garlic cheesy bread
chicken kickers which are just like
nuggets with a spicy coating pretty
recently they've added these popping
chicken bites to the menu which kind of
similar to kfc's popcorn chicken you can
also get chicken strippers which is just
kind of like chicken tenders potato
wedges if you wanted some kind of potato
option to go with your pizza and then
you can also get a tub of coleslaw
i don't think we have garlic cheesy
bread but we do have this which is like
a stuffed cheese bread also the side
they have these uh chicken pieces and
then these right over here these
parmesan
cheese kind of bread nuts
also i think it's pretty cool this
dominoes will hook you up with a side of
grated parmesan that's pretty nice
chicken carbonara which is a pasta dish
what looks like obviously chicken
bits of bacon onion
in the u.s
domino's offers a lot of different
varieties of sandwiches
i just picked one i got the chicken parm
sandwich let's take a look at that right
there
look at that chicken parm
how good does that look
classic garden salad we found something
green on the menu which is nice
um
let's get here tomatoes onions cheese
lettuce croutons
who cares
now the default dipping sauce that will
come with your pizzas is this garlic and
herb dip in the uk but there are also a
couple of sources which are exclusive to
the uk these include a little pop of
frank's red hot sauce and we can also
get a honey mustard
the dominoes in the us has their own
exclusive sauces uh this kicker hot
sauce
um the sweet mango habanero sauce this
one is really good
uh ranch you guys don't have ranch i
thought you did guess not blue cheese
dressing
and of course marinara sauce and finally
if you're someone with a sweet tooth
domino's has some exclusive dessert
items to the uk firstly we've got
domino's cookies which are actually like
really good especially if you get them
when they're warm and they kind of stay
warm when they rest on the pizza boxes
and then you can also get a range of ben
jerry's flavors from domino's in the uk
they're like a licensed fender which is
cool and for dessert in the us you can
get either these marbled cookie brownies
or
these chocolate lava crunch cakes they
also threw in this the sweet icing
i'm sure it's amazing so you can pour
more sugar all over the sugar
let's put some icing on the lava guy
oh
that's too much stop
i gotta get i gotta i gotta get this i'm
gonna like eat this whole tray i gotta
get out of my face i'm ready to destroy
these brownies
from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between subway in the uk and the us
this is food wars
this was probably the first time i had
subway in 10 years now that actually
surprised me because the way you slid
the party sub out of its container
looked like something that you've done a
lot of times called acting i'm a natural
that was actually the first take we did
of that too funny story about that party
sub i ended up giving it to our
cameraman and he took it to a party and
his bro buddies were like yo
the subway in the uk you can get
sandwiches in four different sizes
firstly we have toasted bites
a six inch sub
a foot long sub
and then
you can get a platter
and in the u.s we have three sizes the
six
inch the footlong
yeah you go for you and your team
ah
the big boy
party platter the old subway platypus
now in the uk a platter looks like this
what they do is they make four foot long
sandwiches then they cut those into
fours so you're left with 16 pieces each
of which is three inches and for the
party platter here they take five
sandwiches cutting them into three
pieces giving you 15 sandwiches total in
addition in the us you can also get
yourself
a three foot long party sub
look at this thing this is ridiculous
three feet so that is
what's that in what you got in the uk
that's 17 meters
i have no idea
yeah
now in the uk drinks at subway come in
two sizes
we have a regular which is 400
milliliters
20 ounce spray it would up and we have a
large
30 ounce
boom
if you're really thirsty
40
ounces of soda
40 ounces is a little over three cans of
soda
that is way too much soda
this is way too much just too much
if you're a fan of subway's cookies in
the uk those come in three sizes
one cookie
three cookies
four
twelve
cookies in the u.s subway you can get
a single cookie
a dozen cookies
like that
or
the
hang on keep rolling
the
36 cookie platter booyah
[Laughter]
i'm like in vegas baby all in
we want to make sure that you're getting
the same amount of filling as you do in
the u.s here in the uk so what we've got
here is a foot long italian bmt on
hearty italian with lettuce and olives
we're going to weigh it to see if the
quantities are the same
all right bmp
so the weights are pretty similar what
we're going to do is take them apart and
see how it all adds up
so when it comes to the amount of
filling that you get in your subs it
looks like the uk and the us are
actually pretty identical
so what about calories we found out that
the most popular sub at subway is
actually the turkey breast sub so if you
were to walk into a uk subway and order
a regular turkey breast sub and then
make it a meal by including a regular
drink and a cookie you'd be looking at
621 calories
that same order in the u.s is 690
calories
now the sub itself is actually less
calories it's only 250 but the drink the
medium coke is around 240 and the cookie
is 200 calories but wait according to
the internet in the us the default
actually comes with
two cookies which brings it to a grand
total of 890 calories
what about the calories in another sub
well in the uk six inches of meatball
marinara comes in at 492 calories in the
u.s six inch meatball there's only 430
calories yo
now because we're not sure why our
meatball serve is more calorific we're
actually gonna do another test we're
gonna bring back our friend the scales
and we're gonna weigh a meatball
delicious
boom
and now i will also weigh
one meatball
i'll find a good one
don't want the sauce to
throw off these measurements getting
real close get in real close over there
ready you close
close
here we go drumroll
and
how much is it
no change
our scale is not very accurate
sorry
let's get that weight up on the screen
unfortunately subway in the uk doesn't
disclose a full ingredients list however
there are some things we can glean from
the website in the uk the ham turkey
breast and steak that you'll find in
your sandwiches are actually formed the
turkey bologna and the turkey salami are
also made by a process known as
mechanically separated turkey
mechanically
separated
turkey
from the allergens list in the uk we can
also see that our meatballs contain milk
although it's not clear if the meatballs
contain the milk or if it just comes
with cheese by default we do have the
ingredients list of the meatball
sandwich at subway and i'll read that to
you right now
oh boy beef water bread crumbs and then
we have the kind of square brackets
toasted wheat crumbs and now we have the
curved brackets enriched wheat flour now
we have the fancy brackets wheat flour
niacin reduced iron thiamine
mono nitrate riboflavin folic acid close
fancy brackets sugar salt soybean oil
yeast let me close the other two
brackets aha textured soy protein
concentrate seasoning open brackets
again
dehydrated onion and garlic salt spices
dehydrated parsley soybean oil close
brackets uh soy protein concentrate and
the romano cheese can you scroll up
please
keep going keep going
the romano cheese which is made from
pasteurized part skin cow's milk ugh
i'm assuming it's skim cow's milk but to
be honest if i told you there was cow
skin in this food would you be surprised
part skim
cow's milk cheese cultures salts and
enzymes which enzymes you ask they're
not at liberty to say but rest assured
there are enzymes now on the bright side
the dough is pretty much normal for the
classic italian bread the ingredients
are enriched flour which is wheat flour
niacin reduced iron thymine mino nitrate
nitrate yeah okay riboflavin folic acid
water yeast sugar soybean oil salt wheat
gluten cultured wheat flour malted
barley flour sunflower lechathan
lecithin lecathon
hey did you hear that
lecithin sunflower lecithin dough
conditioner which also has enzymes which
ones you know now and ascorbic acid
all that stuff
while we might have an ingredients list
for our bread we do know that it's
likely to not be perfect for example an
irish court recently declared that
subway cannot call its loaves bread due
to the high sugar content subway uses
more than 10
sugar in their flour
here's everything you can only find on
the menu at a uk subway so let's start
with the subs now there are a few kind
of default subs that you can only find
in the uk so then once you've chosen
your sub and your bread we've also got a
few other customization options that are
exclusive to the uk for example in this
sub we've combined a bunch of them so
i've gone for chicken tikka it has hash
browns it has sweet corn it has vegan
garlic aioli it has hp brown sauce and
it has whole grain mustard so brown
sauce is kind of a traditional british
condiment um the biggest brand
manufacturer of it is a brand called hp
which stands for houses of parliament to
maybe give a nod harry
are you really brit-splaining to me hp
sauce i love hp sauce i've been i've
been having hp sauce had a bottle of hp
sauce in my fridge for at least the past
20 years
over here we have the meatless meatball
marinara sub with some vegan mozzarella
cheese as well and it's on chili paprika
bread our exclusive customizations in
the us include avocado pepper jack
cheese provolone swiss cheese and banana
peppers if you like your sauce you can
make your sauce
if you like a saucy sub you can have the
sauciest subway saucy sub here in the
united sauce because we have all these
sauces including a balsamic sub sauce a
creamy sriracha a deli brown mustard
yellow mustard you guys don't have
yellow mustard
that can't be right
sorry if you have yellow mustard i
thought that was everywhere uh
oil
oil
you guys don't have oil either
okay
uh subway herb and garlic oil ranch red
wine vinaigrette and a special sub spice
so moving the subs to one side for a
second
we also have some side dishes which are
exclusive to the uk
let's start with this which kind of
surprised me when i saw it on the menu
but you can actually just get a cup of
meatballs from subway next we have the
garlic cheesy bread which i think is
just half of the hearty italian six inch
with some garlic butter on it and then
they kind of sprinkle some cheese on top
and throw it in the toaster oven
the last side dish is nachos they
actually just get some doritos throw
them into a box give you some cheese
some jalapenos
that is an insult to nachos those are
the kind of nachos you make in your 20s
when you're drunk or two in the morning
chips cheese microwave it throw on some
salsa that is the most depressing plate
of notches ever seen
that is the worst thing associated
excuse me that is the second worst thing
associated with the subway franchise the
only exclusive side that you can get at
a subway in the u.s is the applesauce
pouch which
we don't have unfortunately the two
subways we went to did not have them
available could we get a
graphic of the
apple sauce pouch on the screen
somewhere near my head
yeah it looks like that now we wanted to
get as many uk exclusives into one sub
as possible so
this is my creation
i'll be clear this is not my usual order
you've got the tang of the brown sauce
with the little popping sweetness of the
sweetcorn
and i just got like a whole hash brown
in there as well
do not order the uk only sub and of
course
we put together a sub with all the usa
only ingredients which is a footlong
barbecue rib sandwich with the jalapeno
cheddar bread and avocado and pepper
jack cheese and provolone cheese and
swiss cheese and banana peppers ah the
us with banana peppers i don't know what
our thing is with banana peppers
i'm not into banana peppers i don't know
why they're so popular here
that's actually pretty good
i actually like that
the jalapeno bread
wow
oh man the sriracha sauce ooh and the
avocado well it's got some heat to it
too
i'm i'm totally surprised i kind of like
that
[Music]
from calorie council portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between burger king in the us and the uk
this is food wars
[Music]
two words together and a number frygate
2020.
in the uk we have three drink sizes
we have a small which is 250 milliliters
this is a us smart we have a regular
which is 400 milliliters this is a us
medium and we have a lodge in here
the u.s large
burger king
now in the uk we have three sizes of
fries small regular and large
here's a burger king small fry
here's a burger king medium fry
and
a burger king
large fry
so the three sizes of fries that we were
given i'm actually not sure which one is
the regular and which one is the small
because these two kind of look identical
we're going to weigh them all
we're going to start with this orange
bottomed bag
80
88 grams now we're gonna weigh the
slightly darker orange bag and see which
size this is
so there's only a five gram difference
but this one is b small
so a large rise in the uk looks like
it's around 180 grams which is double
the
regular scale
we're actually having some concerns
about the sizes of the fries in the uk
because our measurements showed that the
lighter orange bag actually contained
more fries than the darker orange bag
however when lined up very
scientifically like this what we'll
actually see
is that
the bag sizes go up in that color order
instead so i think what's happened here
is that our small was actually bigger
than our regular wow a lot of fried
drama over there in the uk as you can
see from our sizes it's pretty obvious
with the small medium enlarges but of
course we're still going to weigh them
so let's start with the small fry
yep oh
rogue fry and now the medium fry
i'm making a face i don't like that face
it's like
yeah it's pretty similar
i know how we will solve this
but
not not that way over here burger king
is in the hot seat baby burger king's in
the hot seats
large fries
[Applause]
so i'm gonna do something really tedious
and boring
two
three
four 12
13
20 21 22 35 regulars 10 kind of broken
up ones
one
two
34 and 18 but they'll have smaller ones
whoa
that's pretty cold burger king that is
pretty cold don't act like you're
surprised by this and i know what
they're gonna say they're gonna be like
well everyone who scoops it's different
okay but our scooper
here and their scooper in the uk made a
similar
error
hmm
suspicious right
frygate 2020.
so this is a whopper in the uk
no it's not that's a halloumi king
is this the whopper
i forgot
burger king
so what we're going to do is weigh a
whopper and see how much a whopper
weighs in the uk
[Music]
all right let's take a look at the us
whopper
first thing i'm gonna do i'm gonna weigh
it
oh yeah
that's a whopper
oh yeah
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
be scientific about it
in the uk you can get burger king's
chicken fries in three sizes
a six piece box
a
nine piece box
or if you're really hungry
a twenty piece box
in the u.s according to the burger king
website they have three sizes of chicken
fries we went to like five burger kings
two and both of them said that they only
have one size the nine piece chicken
fries i don't know why that is and after
burger king frygate 2020
i'm gonna count these
there's nine
so what about calories well for example
a large whopper meal the whopper itself
is 627 calories
our 180 gram serving of large fries
would be 437 calories and a large coke
would be 209 calories
that brings a total of a large whopper
meal in the uk to
1273 calories
and in the u.s burger king the whopper
meal comes in at a hefty 1600 calories
that is an increase of about 378
calories or roughly 30 percent however
there are ways to bring the calorie
count down for example if you get the
whopper without mail you save yourself
about 157 calories taking the whopper
down to like 503 the drink is a major
culprit if you get a sugar-free soda
like a diet coke you immediately save
yourself 510 calories so with these
minor adjustments you can get a large
whopper meal for about
933 calories
now for whatever reason the mayo in the
uk only comes to six calories so i'm not
sure what you guys are putting in your
mayo
now in the uk a bacon double
cheeseburger comes in at 430 calories
and our bacon double cheeseburger in the
u.s only has 404 calories now this has
to be a food wars first or something in
the u.s has less calories than something
in the uk i do want to point out our
bacon double cheeseburger does not come
with mayo so i think that might be the
calorie culprit so we finally found
something that's less calorific in the
u.s than the uk congrats guys
error 404 mayo not found that's funny
like just put that on the screen there
like an error code
unfortunately burger king does not
disclose the full ingredients list in
either the uk or the us
here are some things that you can only
get at a uk burger king so here we have
the veggie bean burger which you get
these two fried bean patties with some
lettuce some mayo and some cheese here
we have the halloumi king which is kind
of exciting
it comes with lettuce mayo onions tomato
and then these two fried pieces of
halloumi
they also offer that with bacon which
seems slightly counterproductive if
you're a vegetarian but pretty delicious
if you're not
hey siri
what is halloumi
halloumi is a semi
unripened cheese made from a mixture of
goats and sheep's milk and sometimes
also cow's milk
do you want me to keep reading
yes
it has a high melting point and so can
easily be fried or grilled this property
makes it a popular meat substitute
when it is used to curdle the milk in
halloween production although no
acid-producing bacteria are used in its
preparation
thanks
i don't want that
at the back here we have a chicken
royale with bacon which is a longer
chicken patty that's fried comes with
lettuce bacon and cheese and mayo
to round out the burgers we have the
bacon king
which is kind of like a larger version
of the bacon double cheeseburger but it
also has mayo on it and then finally
available to us right now we have the
jalapeno chicken fries which are kind of
like the standard chicken fries but with
a spicy jalapeno coating
i'm furious we don't have those that is
ridiculous how do they have the jalapeno
chicken fries and way down that is
ridiculous so on top of what i've got in
front of me there are also a lot of
exclusives that we have in the uk which
i'll read for you now
the steakhouse angus a classic cheese
melt a barbecue double melt a chili
cheese melt the roadhouse crispy chicken
sandwich a crispy bacon king
a rebel whopper mac and cheese bites
chili cheese bites apple slices a
breakfast king a range of breakfast
sandwiches including a bacon butty and a
sausage butty porridge and an oreo
fusion which is like an ice cream with
some oreos in it it has to be said that
burger king isn't the friendliest place
for vegetarians they have some kind of
vegetarian options like the halloumi
king or the rebel whopper but
unfortunately these are actually cooked
in the same oil and on the same grills
as the meat so it's not 100 vegetarian
here is everything that is exclusive to
the burger king in the united states uh
i'm just gonna start
here
impossible whopper
even when we're trying to be healthy we
still manage to figure out a way to be
unhealthy there's stuff in our
impossible meat that has not been
approved in the uk yet
crispy taco here in burger king usa only
i don't know why there's tacos
at burger king
i don't know who's getting a taco at
burger king that's ridiculous
crispy
the stacker
oh bacon
the double stacker these things are so
heavy
this is so much now from my
understanding what separates the stacker
from the bacon double cheeseburger is
these are quarter pound patties and also
there's some sort of stacker sauce on
here special stacker sauce
spicy crispy chicken sandwich
the barbecue bacon crispy chicken
sandwich
spicy
chicken sandwich junior
for the little guys
you can also get
another mozzarella sticks four with
marinara in there uh applesauce
oh yeah breakfast oh good lord all right
so
you get pancakes and of course syrup and
of course we're gonna do a a syrup for
wouldn't it be a food wars episode
without me pouring something on
something else
you like that you like how that looks
ah yes
the chris sandwich so as you can see
what a chris sandwich is is a breakfast
sandwich where a croissant is the buns
how's it look
look good
and
also simmer to mcdonald's
breakfast sandwiches they also have
breakfast biscuits also sausage egg and
cheese
uh and then last the u.s
burger king breakfast burrito
let's open it up let's take a look
inside
look at the egg
that's sausage oh they got potato in
here
okay
i wouldn't i would not
get this but good for them good effort
last night
you can also get yourself a hershey's
sunday chocolate pie oh look at that
look at that
oh man i don't want to jump into that
from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between uk and us starbucks this is food
wars
now i do have a confession to make which
is that i don't drink coffee i'm very
loyal to tea as a british person so this
episode was kind of wasted on me
now hot coffees in the uk come in four
sizes
firstly we have a short coffee which is
eight ounces the short eight ounces then
we have a tall coffee
which is 12 ounces next we have the tar
next 12 ounces it's a grande coffee
which comes in at 16 ounces then we got
the grande
16 ounces aventi or 20 ounces
sensational and the biggest one
the venti
20 ounces
in case you're wondering it's called the
venti because 20 in italian is venti
tuento
just to double check we're going to
measure the largest hot coffee in the uk
so our venti coffee actually came to
closer to 18 ounces sort that out
starbucks where's my two ounces
now i'm going to measure the venti
coffee which should be 20 ounces
minus a few sips
wait
okay prepared
whoa come on i did not drink that much
oh starbucks
that's not no that's not even two that's
like an ounce
the cold coffees in the uk come in three
sizes
they're tall
the tall 12 ounces
grand bay we got the grande
and fenty here's where things get kind
of weird our venti iced is 24 ounces and
we have another size up 20 right
trent
and that is
30 ounces
so a uk cold venti is exactly 20 ounces
yeah 21. i thought this was supposed to
be 24.
how many
fluid ounces
venti
nice
24
and how much is it 21
starbucks
with the ice you still don't have enough
i'm taking a sip of every single drink
i'm taking a sip of every single drink
let's do this
let's compare some seemingly identical
drinks to see how much they match up
under the hood so aventi latte in the uk
contains 235 calories 7.9 grams of fat
21.1 grams of sugar and 225 milligrams
of caffeine and in the u.s the same
venti latte has 250 calories and that's
9 grams of fat and 150 milligrams of
caffeine and you know i'm taking a sip
kind of cold it's been sitting out for
hours so our latte's got more sugar more
calories and more fat the trinity of
deliciousness is what i call it let's
try something a little heavier if you
were to order a venti caramel
frappuccino from a uk starbucks it would
contain 426 calories 61.1 grams of sugar
and 117 milligrams of caffeine
harry your frappuccinos are looking a
little sad there buddy looks like all
your whipped cream melted so here's a
pro tip from the usa
470 calories 74 carbs 73 of which are
sugar and 120 milligrams of caffeine
damn oh yuck
yuck
that's what that tastes like
now it's important to remember that for
cold drinks like frappuccinos the us
venti is actually four fluid ounces
larger than the uk's if you were to do
the math to work out the nutrition per
fluid ounce the uk actually beats the us
in virtually every metric let's see if
we can get any clues as to why from the
ingredients
now in the uk a cappuccino from
starbucks contains just two ingredients
milk and brewed espresso
and in the u.s our cappuccinos are made
from milk and brewed espresso look at
that same thing finally
[Music]
now for the most part the hot coffees in
both countries are just those two
ingredients in different quantities
things get a little bit more complicated
once you start to add things like syrups
however for example in the uk if you add
caramel syrup to your cappuccino it adds
the following ingredients sugar water
natural flavoring concentrate of apple
carrot hibiscus molasses citric acid and
potassium sorbet
whereas our caramel syrup has sugar corn
syrup butter cream milk salt
uh water heavy cream non-fat dry milk
natural flavors salt
mono-digly psoriasis i don't know what
that word is
soy lecithin and sulfides the point is
our caramel syrup is actual caramel in
it how do you like that
now let's try something with a lot more
ingredients this is a java chip
frappuccino from the uk and it contains
the following
ice ice milk milk coffee frappuccino
syrup which is sugar water natural
flavor salt
potassium
ladies and gentlemen it is a food wars
first the first time something in the uk
has an ingredients list longer than
something in the u.s tend to celebrate
baby
[Music]
here is everything you can only find on
the menu at a uk starbucks
and this is everything you can get in a
u.s starbucks now we'll start with a
quick disclaimer one of the big selling
points of starbucks is that you can
heavily customize pretty much everything
on the menu to save ourselves doing a
million different combinations of
exclusive items what we're going to do
is focus mostly on things that are on
the menu as they are we're just like a
few combinations of syrups and toppings
that you can get in one or the other
firstly we have this cute little cortado
secondly we have a cold foam cappuccino
which is like an iced cappuccino with
just some foam on top of it then we have
some temporary season exclusive so at
the moment you can get a peanut butter
cup frappuccino in the uk as well as a
chocolate s'mores frappuccino which
sounds pretty damn good in the u.s along
with the blonde roast you can get in the
uk we also have a dark roast and we have
something called the pike place roast
now that roast is a tribute to the first
starbucks that's near the pike place
market in seattle washington i've been
to that starbucks it's fine
exclusive to the u.s we have the caramel
cloud macchiato
oh i do not like that
the
mocha cookie crumble frappuccino
the caramel ribbon crunch frappuccino i
mean the regular caramel one was gross
let's see how this one is
oh god it's worse oh it's so much worse
and we also have this a vanilla sweet
cream cold brew the ice has melted
woof
i bet that was good six hours ago when
it was made
and what we've done is combine as many
uk exclusives as we can into one drink
which i'm calling the uk only
we've got some almond some sugar-free
caramel some sugar-free hazelnut and
some mango which is going to be an
interesting mix
that is sweet
and of course at the starbucks in the
u.s we have our own unique
customizations for instance pineapple
ginger syrup raspberry syrup toffee nut
syrup a cascara topping
cinnamon dolce sprinkles we have
chocolate cinnamon nutmeg and vanilla
powders and a whole range of cold foams
so of course i went ahead and had all
those things put in to one drink which
i'm calling the usa only
oh man that's weird
nothing
in that works together
um
that cathy started
baby it's starting
[Music]
[Music]
starbucks
now this series isn't called drink wars
and thankfully starbucks has lots of
food items here are some things you'll
only find on the menu at a uk starbucks
let's start with the bakery section here
in the uk on the bakery menu you will
find a chocolate chunk shortbread cookie
you will find this delightful little
gingerbread barista map you you'll find
this panoraza
we also have some
luxury fruit toast which comes with
these little cute pots of jam
and then finally we've got a cinnamon
swell which is kind of just a cinnamon
roll
our breakfast options are slightly
limited most of what we have is a range
of breakfast rolls which is just kind of
like a breakfast sandwich in the uk but
served on crusty white bread some
options include a bacon sandwich
bacon sandwiches are a pretty big deal
over here for that moment okay
and then also if you want something a
little bit more you can go for an
all-day breakfast sandwich which is
bacon sausage and egg all in one roll
here are all the u.s exclusive food
items so a lot of different breakfast
sandwiches for starbucks this one right
here
is the impossible
meat
sandwich
spinach egg and feta cheese wrap this is
my go-to one love it these egg bites
these little
i'm gonna definitely pronounce this
wrong these little suit v egg wraps sued
v
i'll be straight up i've never had one
of these
holy these are so good
[Music]
oh my god
a lot of baked goods like this little
friendly guy just in time for the
holiday season a little snowman cake pop
a bunch of different varieties of sugar
cookies i got this one because i think
it looks the nicest but i don't want
this at all
oh but you know i do love dude danishes
especially cheese danishes we also got
scones
so one with the blueberry scone
we gotta harry's face on there
let's go and hear him
sorry to break it too joe but that is
not a scone a few things to point out
firstly it's pronounced scone not scone
secondly they should all the marshmallow
dream bar aka a rice crispy treat
what are we doing
we're going to starbucks in the morning
and we're getting cookies and rice
krispies treats for breakfast
no
no
[Music]
they got bagels
i asked for cream cheese and they forgot
pumpkin cream cheese muffin it's got
pumpkin little glob of cream cheese in
it right there
muffins are okay in the morning i'm pro
morning muffin last and probably least
because i've never had one nor if i ever
wanted one
starbucks in the u.s have a lot of what
they call protein boxes
chicken and quinoa
looks like
a salad
you guys have pretty much all the lunch
options that we have in terms of like
paninis sandwiches and wraps one thing i
did want to highlight was this which is
a cheese and marmite mini ciabatta
so marmite as some of you will know is a
spread that's quite popular in the uk
it's like the byproduct of making beer
when the yeast ferments it kind of
leaves like a sludge on the bottom of
the tank and that is mermaid but it
somehow tastes really good
harry no tamarmite it's bad stop it
so on top of classic english breakfast
tea we also have some exclusive teas to
the uk so we'll start with the jasmine
pearl green tea which is just our
exclusive version of the green tea here
we've got something called a youth berry
tea which apparently helps keep you
young
here is some chamomile tea which is
great if you want something to relax
before bed then we've got some frozen
teas as well so this is a frozen iced
tea made with apple and kiwi this is a
frozen iced tea with tropical mango and
then this is a frozen strawberry and
lime tea here in the u.s we have a lot
of exclusive teas too these are those
exclusive teas
for hot ones we have a jade citrus mint
uh a peach tranquility tea i think they
missed a trick they're not calling it
the peach tranquility
counter blade came up with that not me
uh the revved up tea right there and
then for the cold ones we got the royal
english breakfast tea why don't you guys
have the iced royal english breakfast
tea
uh
a matcha lemonade tea a iced guava black
tea and the passion tango iced tea
from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between us and uk papa john's this is
food wars
personally when i get a pizza from a
place like papa john's i just get cheese
and pepperoni but shooting these
episodes it's got me a chance to try a
bunch of different things on the menu
and i'm actually kind of impressed with
things like their desserts now that
you've been forced to try a few are
there any that you're gonna order again
in the future uh you're just gonna have
to watch the episode and find out
in the uk our sizes start at small ours
is 9.5 inches across with a surface area
of 71 square inches
our small pizza comes in at 10 inches
which is 78.5 square inches of pizza
next up we have our medium pizza it's
11.5 inches across with a surface area
of 103.8 square inches
our large 14 inches which is
153.9 square inches
finally for some reason we skip extra
large and go straight to extra extra
large this one's 15.5 inches across with
a surface area of 188.7 square inches
we didn't skip the extra large 16 inches
right here that's 201 square izzo's
episode our extra-large is bigger than
your extra extra large in your face
harry
in the uk a small cheese pizza will cost
you 11.99 which is around 15.54 that's a
price per square inch of 21.8 cents
small in the u.s 9.49 which is about 12
cents per square inch
i know i got a small
but apparently they're also doing small
peppers with the small pizzas look how
small this is
skimping on the peppers eh papa
an xxl cheese pizza in the uk will cost
you around
23.32 cents which is a price of 12.3
cents per square inch
usa's extra-large 15.49
that cannot be right sprinkle a little
math on that that's 7.7 cents per square
inch that is so cheap
so what can we take away from this well
in both countries the more pizza you buy
the cheaper it gets in the us the price
per square inch of a small is 55 percent
more than an extra large and in the uk
it shoots up to a huge 77 percent more
i mean it makes sense right i mean
that's how they get you they pretty much
are tricking you into getting more pizza
because it's cheap per square inch so
you're going i'll just get the extra
large instead and then a year later
you're fat
[Laughter]
whoops it was such a good deal
it is worth noting that paying full
price is kind of rare in the uk we got
like a 40 off deal because we spent a
certain amount of money basically if
you're paying full price in the uk
you're really not getting the best value
for money i'm on the website right now
and it looks like yeah they have endless
specials or deals so pretty much every
combination you want to get large
one-topping pizza any two sides two
large pizzas i'm assuming what papa
john's does is have all types of deals
and codes and promotions that whatever
you get when you order papa john's is
probably a deal for you so you probably
are never paying full price
in the uk an extra extra large cheese
pizza is cut into 12 slices each of
these 12 slices is 268 calories which
brings a total to a whopping
3218 calories
in the u.s our extra-large is cut into
10 slices that means each slice is
roughly 300 calories
and there is no possible way you're
eating this pizza without the sauce
what about the most calorific thing on
the menu in the uk it's a sausage and
pepperoni pizza
now for an xxl version of this pizza
each slice is 355 calories that brings
the total to
4260 calories
in the u.s if you're going for most
calories it's a tie between the meats
pizza and the pepperoni sausage and
three cheese pizza this used to be
john's favorite they changed the name
they took his name off of it when he
left i wonder what happened to that guy
each pizza is roughly 410 calories per
slice and since it's 10 slices per pizza
that is a whopping 4 100 calories per
pizza
so despite the average pizza sizes being
smaller in the uk the pizzas themselves
are actually more calorific who knew
[Music]
now despite papa john's motto being
better ingredients better pizza they
don't actually make their full
ingredients list available in the uk we
did reach out to them to see if they'd
make an exception for us but at the time
of shooting this unfortunately we hadn't
heard back
now because we can't get the uk papa
john's ingredients list we're going to
tweak this section a little bit we're
going to compare the u.s papa john's
ingredients to another very popular fast
food pizza chain dominance let's get
domino's dough ingredients on the screen
okay now let's compare that with the
papa john's u.s dough ingredients
unbleached enriched wheat flour water
sugar soybean oil salt yeast
and that's it
how hilarious is that see it doesn't
need to be a whole
chemistry lab
okay i gotta give papa john's props
that's really great they say fresher
ingredients and they mean it i like that
here is everything you can only find on
the menu at a uk papa john's and these
are all the usa exclusive items you can
get at papa john's
let's start with the pizzas so in front
of me i have three pizzas and across
these three we've covered pretty much
all of the items you can only find on
the menu at uk papa john's so what i
have right in front of me here is a
pizza with a butternut squash base now
this is on the menu as a gluten-free
alternative to traditional doughs then
the pizzas outside of that as you can
see have a stuffed crust which is just a
classic crust but then folded over and
filled with a kind of cheesy garlicky
mix which is really really good this
right here is a pizza consisting of only
the toppings and crusts that you can get
in the u.s we have the parmesan cheese
garlic crusted crust crusted crust now
from there you can also customize the
base sauce so instead of the tomato
sauce on this one we have an amarillo
chili sauce i was not aware of this
until recently but apparently at a papa
john's in the united states you can
substitute the tomato sauce for ranch
and i did exactly that because there's
nothing more american than ranch
dressing papa john's in the uk actually
offers quite a few vegetarian and vegan
options for example again on this pizza
instead of the classic mozzarella blend
cheese we have a vegan cheese which is a
cheese alternative that's friendly for
vegans so in the uk you can top your
pizza with anchovies with tuna with
tandoori chicken with spicy beef and
also some fake meat alternatives such as
vegan pepperoni and also a vegan sausage
finally we have a couple of vegetarian
toppings for example on this pizza we
have some red chillies and on this pizza
we have feta cheese and sweet corn
cheese we did do the parmesan romano and
the three cheese blend which is
provolone fontana fontania fanta
whatever and asiago cheeses salami
canadian bacon the philly cheesesteak
stuff spinach and also of course banana
peppers i don't know what it is
with banana peppers they're suddenly on
everything
i don't get it alright
here we go all right positive mental
attitude pma i'm about to have the usa
only
no i don't like that
i admit it's growing on me
i wouldn't pick the ranch sauce
i would stick with tomato
being not bad oh
god that's not good
oh man don't don't order this don't
order the uk only pizza
moving swiftly on from the uk only pizza
here are some sides you can only find on
the menu at a uk papa john's we've got
some vegan cauliflower wings
it's basically just small pieces of
cauliflower that are breaded and fried
and then you can kind of dip them in a
sauce of your choice just a nice chicken
wing alternative for vegetarians
here we've got some chicken poppers now
i think these are available in the us
but the one that's exclusive to the uk
is the tandoori chicken spice one which
is just pieces of chicken breaded and
fried with an indian spice blend
here we've got some tater tots which i'm
surprised you guys can't get in the us
because these aren't really a thing in
the uk but here we can get tater tots
you can get them with cheese like we
have here or you can also get them with
cheese and bacon and then finally again
surprising you don't have these in the
us these are some jalapeno poppers just
kind of mini jalapenos breaded fried
with some cheese inside now i'm super
excited to try these these are marmite
scrolls what it is is kind of pieces of
dough rolled up with some cheese and
some marmite in the middle of them now
joe if you've never had marmite it
sounds gross because it's actually harry
yes i actually in fact have had marmite
it was a while ago in college i lived
briefly with a british guy he had a jar
of it i did try it once i don't remember
exactly how it tasted but i do recall
comparing it to the taste of vomit so
suffice to say i'm in the not fan of
marmite category so far the papa john's
sides game is pretty strong now for
wings we have a honey chipotle
wing sauce garlic knots
oh man
dude this thing is drenched in their
butter i'm confused by this next usa
only thing it is called a papadia i mean
it's a calzone but for some reason
they're calling it a papadia which i
assume is a play-off of quesadilla
yeah look
they're just
it's just it's just the pizza that they
cut and folded over right moving on
these look good these look right up my
alley these are the uh jalapeno popper
rolls and ranch forgot you also got
breadsticks
here's some u.s exclusive sauces
spicy garlic ranch of course
honey mustard
blue cheese
regular cheese
and
you can also get big surprise
uh side of banana peppers also cider
jalapenos
and i was as surprised as anyone to see
also in the u.s you can get
these
cider anchovies
finally for those of you with a sweet
tooth papa john's in the uk has a few
exclusive desserts we have some
chocolate scrolls on my right and some
cinnamon scrolls on my left and then
finally we have some ben jerry's papa
john's in the uk is kind of like a ben
jerry's license vendor which is quite
cool and then also we can get some
milkshakes here which are a brand called
for real and they're not bad
and for dessert
the one thing we got that you don't have
uk cinnamon pull-aparts again apologies
it's been sitting for a while
dude
yes to these
from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between taco bell in the us and the uk
this is food wars
taco bell we're talking tacos at the u.s
taco bell you can get an individual hard
shell taco
or you can get
three
with
a drink i went with medium or you can
get a party pack which is 12. yay get a
load of this it's like i'm
presenting a newborn
[Laughter]
the serving sizes for tacos in the uk
are one individual taco or
two tacos fries and a drink which is a
combo meal this is a u.s beef taco
supreme first thing i'm gonna do is
measure it hang on oh man it's almost
exactly six inches all right let's weigh
it
new scale
oh over 100 grams this is a crunchy beef
taco supreme in the uk
it measures
exactly five inches across
and it weighs
70 grams
wow that's way heavier
what is up this is a standard burrito in
the uk we've gone for crispy chicken i
also want with chicken
it measures
six and a half inches in length oh you
know what
six and a half inches
about 210 grams
uh 230.
here's our quesadilla it is
yo dude it's a foot 12 inches this is a
uk chicken quesadilla it measures 10
inches in length and it weighs
245 grams yeah about 245
weighs the same
wider
crunchwrap supreme
this is a crunchwrap supreme in the uk
it measures
six inches points a point
and it
weighs about 240 grams what's six cents
without looking it up does anyone know
what a six-sided shape is hey siri
what is a six-sided shape
according
hexagons
yo dude
guess how many inches
six baby
that is obviously that's on purpose i
wonder if there's something about
six sides six inches
if this thing weighs 666 grams i will
never not eat these here we
go 275
for the hexagon crunchwrap supreme six
sides six inches
what's the biggest thing on the uk menu
well for us it's the classic cravings
meal for six
in the us biggest thing on the menu
remember this guy
taco party pack the classic cravings
meal for six comes with
two quesadillas two beef crunch wrap
supremes two volcano burritos two
portions of nachos belgrande and then
six beef tacos and three portions of
cinnamon twists for dessert as you can
see it's just 12 tacos i know that seems
very simple but sometimes simplicity is
the best 12 tacos you can get them
either hard shell or soft shell regular
or supreme at least half of them i know
you can get as doritos tacos locos if
you don't know what that is you'll find
it a little bit later here in the u.s
let's take a look at some of the
nutritional info for taco bell starting
with the basics in the uk a plain
crunchy beef taco is 159 calories and
has 308 milligrams of sodium
in the u.s our crunchy beef taco is 170
calories a chicken quesadilla in the uk
is a hefty 529 calories our quesadilla
actually has less calories only 510 but
it still has more sodium actually has
almost more than half of your daily
allowance third well in the uk a
crunchwrap has 578 calories but
shockingly it has 60 of your daily
saturated fat allowance in the us our
hexagram is 530 calories and is about 6
grams of fat less than the one in the uk
but
surprising no one ours has more sodium
as is always the case in the u.s you
have to look at the beverages this right
here is a large mountain dew baja blast
this is 30 ounces of a liquid that is
the most unnatural green i've ever seen
it glows in the dark it's so bright when
i close my eyes i can still see it like
when you look at the sun
this beverage has over 420
calories that is ridiculous i gotta take
a sip
oh my god this has roughly
110 grams of sugar it's an absurd amount
of sugar
oh god it's like it's horrible yet i'm
addicted to it so i wanted to see
exactly what
110 grams of sugar looks like and to do
so
get on my face
we got
this
and this
come on are you serious i'm not even
halfway there
yeah okay there we go
this
is in that
america this is too much sugar
i get it
this thing
it's just
ah
man
i hate that so much
let's start with the ingredients for the
basics in the uk a flour tortilla
contains the following fortified wheat
flour made with wheat flour calcium
carbonate iron niacin and thiamine
and a flower treatment agent e920
here we go
in the u.s our flour tortillas have
enriched wheat flour water vegetable
shortening with soybean hydrogenated
soybean and or cottonseed
oil conditioners
yeah uh
or pony proponent propionates that's a
tough one ascorbic acid and or
potassium sorbate these list might look
quite different but actually a lot of
it's just down to terminology for
example the uk menu tends to use e
numbers whereas the us menu tends to
refer to things by their full chemical
names yeah it's a good distinction to
make harry but is it better i don't know
what sounds worse e450 or pyrophosphate
pyrophosphates
is a scary sounding chemical e450 sounds
like a star wars droid i don't think it
really makes much of a difference
personally what about some meat options
well in the uk 72 of the beef is beef
and the rest is made up of beef fat
maltodextrin tomato powder paprika cumin
black pepper salt chili powder garlic
powder onion powder yeast extract
oregano cocoa powder flavor enhancer
e635
cellulose salt stabilizers e451 and e452
and in the united states our beef
contains beef imagine that
water seasoning which is cellulose chili
pepper maltodextrin salt oats soy
lecithin spices tomato powder sugar
onion powder citric acid natural flavors
new set of brackets including smoke
flavor clothes and brackets tarula yeast
coca
sodium
anociate and
what is this word
guamulates
guanilines guanulinx
what happens uh looks like it's pretty
much the same thing you guys got there
in the uk
one thing we need to note about the us
taco bell menu is that items like the
baja blast and the doritos tacos locos i
think the shells have an ingredient
called yellow number five
yellow number five is not in the uk of
course it's in the u.s in the uk you
usually find yellow five referred to as
tetrazine it's on a list of six
chemicals which when added to food must
contain the following warning
may have an adverse effect on activity
and attention in children
and according to the fda in some cases
it causes itching and hives in people
who eat it disgusting
itching in hives yep that's fine um hey
i ate a growing up and i'm perfectly
fine i should note that i have a full
head of gray hair and i just turned 23.
here is everything you can only find on
the menu at a uk taco bell this is
everything you can only get a us taco
bell so we only have the one exclusive
taco and it's this one which is the
crispy chicken soft taco what it is is
pretty much just a standard taco with
the lettuce the cheese the sour cream
but then we've kind of got one of these
breaded crispy chicken fillets in the
middle as well first thing which is
right in front of me i've talked about
this twice already it is the party pack
uh we've already met the baja blast
oh man i hate it so much one thing
that i love at taco bell the doritos
locos tacos what is it it is a taco that
the shell
is
a dorito see that made of the same stuff
now we actually have a bunch of
exclusive burrito options in the uk
we'll start with this one which is the
volcano burrito now apparently this used
to be on the menu in the us but is no
longer there what it is is basically
just like a beef and rice burrito
there's some sour cream cheese in there
as well and some crunchy tortilla chips
and i think it gets the name volcano
because it's got the lava source in
there so it's quite spicy
yes harry the volcano burrito was
available in the u.s for a limited time
it was a promotional menu item for the
1995
box office bomb congo based on the
michael crichton book r.i.p to my boy
michael crichton here we have a beefy
nacho griller which is a fantastic name
what this is is just beef and crushed
nacho chips with some cheese sauce in a
burrito
here we've got the double cheesy black
bean burrito which as the name suggests
has two types of cheese it's got the
nacho cheese and also the shredded
cheese in there as well as some rice and
black beans here we have the seven layer
burrito we have another exclusive crispy
chicken option which is a crispy chicken
burrito and then finally we have the
spicy chicken griller
not bad
it does just kind of taste like
something that i could make at home
there's a bunch of burritos um i'm gonna
try and figure out what these burritos
are without like completely ripping them
apart this right here
oh beefcake cerrito
somehow they combined a burrito and a
quesadilla and as this
light brown brick if you don't want beef
you want to go uh vegetarian they also
have a black bean quesarito this looks
like five layer burrito i didn't know
this until i had to do this video but
there's no seven layer burrito in
america anymore they took out two layers
and i get the five layer one
what is this
well all these just look the same
grilled cheese burrito
that sounds awesome i don't like grilled
cheese
and these two that are left here one of
them
is
a cheesy bean and rice burrito and the
other one is a burrito supreme
that's one of these two i don't know
which is which we also have steak
quesadillas which unfortunately the taco
bell that i went to did not have them
this big thing right here i love this
look at this this is the nacho party
pack it's exactly what it sounds like
get a good look uk this is what nachos
are supposed to look like now what we
lack in nacho is we more than make up
for and fries we love fries in the uk
obviously we call them chips but it's
very unusual to walk into a fast food
restaurant and not be able to find them
so i think taco bell have kind of tried
to cash in on that in the uk basically
your standard fries but then they have a
kind of feta seasoning on them as well
you can get them in three sizes regular
fries then you have the fries supreme
and then finally you have the fry's
belgrande which is the biggest size we
ordered one deconstructed and one
constructed just to see the difference
mexican pizza uh they were saying for a
while that these were going to be taken
off the menu
we still got them in a couple locations
apparently i got my hands on one look at
this guy
um oh this right here
the powerball the protein bowl this is
actually a
really good idea for them it's just all
protein no carbs now the only side that
seems to be exclusive to the uk is
actually just a little bowl of rice for
some reason i couldn't find this on the
us menu if i was wrong let me know
what everyone
in the uk
has been
waiting for
taco bell breakfast yes
i think
of all the fast food breakfasts
taco bells is the best
these are the items that you can get
here in america and they are all great
a cheesy toasted breakfast burrito
the hash brown toasted burrito
the grande
toasted breakfast burrito another one i
want to point out here is the breakfast
crunchwrap supreme of course we all know
this shape
hexagon
they're like
the regular burritos you'd get at taco
bell but they have eggs in them
sometimes if bacon a pico de gallo
they're all very good very very good i'm
really sad that we don't have any
breakfast items in the uk but what we do
have is churros for dessert
these can be served with a little pot of
dolce de leche to dip in
and honestly i'm shocked that you guys
don't have these
for the us taco bell desserts the one
thing we got here you can't get in the
uk are these cinnabon delights they're
like a little cinnamon balls you can get
them
in either an order of 2 or 12 or any
number in between
oh my god
there's cream inside of these i was not
expecting that exclusive drinks in the
u.s this one is a dragon fruit freeze
that was uh like a slurpee you can also
get powerade they got fruit punch
powerade on tap right here pink lemonade
and uh for the
baja blast
fiends they also have a baja blast
freeze
yuck
in the u.s our taco bell also has
iced coffee and iced tea
from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between five guys in the uk and the us
this is food wars
so harry what did you think of five guys
yeah i thought this episode was really
cool i really enjoyed learning more
about the fries because they appear to
be really good value but if you watch
you'll find out that actually you might
not be getting as much value as you
think
yeah they're not generous okay they
factor the price of the fries into the
extra scoop when you're buying the fries
you're paying for the fried cup and the
extra scoop they factor it in don't get
me started on the hot dog
[Music]
burgers from a uk five guys come in two
sizes five guys in the us also has two
burger sizes firstly we have the little
which is just one patty and the regular
which is
two patties
now our patties are supposed to be
lighter than the us patties and should
weigh 67 grams we're gonna weigh one and
find out if that's accurate
so this patty actually weighed 52 grams
which is 15 grams less than what we're
supposed to get
according to the u.s five guys website
they say that one of the patties should
weigh 94 grams or about 3.3 ounces we
will weigh a hamburger patty in the us-5
guys as a
52-53 grams
it looks like our patties weigh just
about the same as the ones in the uk
we're not sure if they measure it before
or after cooking maybe it's before and
then some of the liquid leaves as it
cooks but either way
not quite what we're expecting
this right here is a hot dog from a us5
guys and before
i
measure it
what in the heck
is this
did you know this they cut the hot dog
in half
i hate that they cut this in half
cursed image okay how long is this
monstrosity six and one-fourth inches
for the hot dog
so a hot dog from a uk five guys is
about six inches in length now like the
burgers this has an estimated weight and
it should weigh 146 grams if the
website's ingredient information is
correct but ours actually weighs 154
grams so we're actually getting more
than expected
okay let's weigh this thing before i
throw it in the ocean
worry about a hair over 150.
okay i want to talk to one of the five
guys
get me guy number three or four i don't
get i don't care i demand to know what
is going on with these hot dogs
five guys chocolate milkshake in the u.s
i believe it's 12 ounces let's see what
it actually is here
this one's a little bit more oh a little
bit more melted
wait wait wait wait wait
oh yeah that's way more than 12 buddy
that's way more than 12.
it is just over
450 milliliters almost
16 ounces
this is a milkshake from a uk five guys
we're going to measure it to find out
how much you get
now the uk portion size is advertised as
454 milliliters we've got just over 400
here if we scraped around the side we
could probably get a few more in there
as well now five guys in the uk is
notorious for overfilling its fried
portions we also get three sizes little
regular and large we ordered all three
and they came in one bag and here's what
we got
little fries
regular fries
large fries
and this is the rest of the bag
now we're not sure which of these fries
belongs to which of these portions so
we're going to try and figure it out in
the u.s we also have three sizes of
fries at the five guys the small
uh the regular
the large
and yes
so
many more fries look at that so all in
all
five guys is very generous with the
fries
i mean i guess i'll start by filling
each cup
and then try and portion this into like
vague threes i guess
yes
that sounds right i don't know if it is
but i'm just going to follow harry's
lead on this one
so this is roughly what we think would
go with each of the portions now in the
uk a regular fries is supposed to weigh
414 grams we're going to weigh the cup
and then also the extras to see if what
you get really is a bonus or if it
actually all adds up to the supposed
total
165.
so first we'll do the scale right
so this is supposed to be 411 grams
let's see what we got
what is this 170
woof guys that's not even close
so our regular cup of fries actually
only contained 165 grams which is less
than half of what you're supposed to get
we're gonna weigh the rest of the fries
to see if that makes up the difference
so even with all the bag fries which we
assigned to the regular portion we're
still only looking at 276 grams which is
well below the portion size you're
supposed to be getting for a regular
excellent idea harry i will do the same
now we are up to
275
still now supposed to be 4 11.
so it looks like we've been a bit short
changed on the fries because it was all
given to us in one big bag it's hard to
tell which portion came out small so
what we're going to do is add the little
fries to this one get a total figure for
all three portions and then figure out
how much we've been shortchanged overall
so we've done the maths and between our
large regular and little fries including
the bag fries we only got
grams however we were supposed to get
1220 grams which means we've been
shortchanged by roughly a third here
frygate 2020.
technically harry this is frygate 2021
check the release schedule
with the rest of the bag fries the large
and the little so they gave us 851
grams of fries total
they're supposed to give us
1225. siri
851 is what percentage of 1225.
69
nice
so at least in our case it seems as if
the generosity of five guys has been a
bit overstated maybe they just overfill
smaller containers so you kind of think
you're getting more than you should be
whereas in reality if you measure it all
you're actually maybe getting less
let's compare the prices of both five
guys and see who's getting the better
deal okay usa this hamburger costs nine
dollars and twelve cents that is way too
much money for this burger a hamburger
from the uk five guys will cost you six
pounds 95 which is equivalent to nine
dollars and twenty cents
the prices do seem similar but it's
actually per gram twenty six percent
less in the us than it is in the uk
what about the fries well in the uk a
large prize is five pounds 25 which
comes to six dollars and ninety five
cents
in the u.s our five guys large after tax
is seven dollars and six cents you must
be joking
if you do the maths for the fries it
turns out that the us is getting a
better deal but only fractionally you
guys get like one percent more value for
your money when it comes to the large
fries so not too mad about that one a
big draw is that when you're in five
guys
they have just crates open with peanuts
and while you're waiting for your food
you just scoop some peanuts and just
like crack the shells open what do you
even mean so if you go in the store and
you wait you can eat like uh you can
peel and eat peanuts and throw the
shells on the floor like it's a saloon
in the 1800s who cares especially if
you're going there to eat let me fill up
in these cheap peanuts before i get this
ridiculously priced food
compared to some of the places that
we've reviewed on this show before five
guys is a more expensive option but i
mean particularly in the uk i don't feel
too mad about paying a bit more for five
guys than i might do for amele
mcdonald's it's just more of a treat but
it does feel a bit more exotic they've
branded themselves as a kind of like
american import americans know their way
around a burger sort of thing so if i go
i know that i'm getting something of a
little bit higher quality than maybe a
standard fast food place even if the
prices are gonna cost me more
i hate five guys the hot dog is
ridiculous i don't care about peanuts
this stuff is way overpriced forget it
let's take a look at the calories of the
five guys cheeseburger that says two
patties two slices of cheese and a bun
and the total calories is 984.
what about a uk cheeseburger well this
one comes to 756 calories which is more
than 200 calories less than the us
burger the us burger doesn't just have
more calories either it's got pretty
much more of everything else it's got
more fat saturate and sodium than a
cheeseburger in the uk
in the uk if they actually give you
what's advertised on the website a large
portion of fries is a hefty
1491 calories but despite that we still
somehow end up with less sodium our
large fine in the us is 1 314 calories i
also want to point out our fries come in
lower than the uk in terms of fat
content as well as saturates and finally
we have the drinks this chocolate shake
out of five guys in the us is 830
calories
a chocolate shake in the uk comes to
slightly more at 891 calories
so what if we combine all three into a
meal so a plain cheeseburger regular
fries and a chocolate shake from five
guys in the u.s totals at
2767 calories yo dog
also i think this is about 70
the same meal in the uk well that comes
to a total of
2769 calories two calories more than in
the us the differences between the
burger and the fries effectively cancel
each other out
let's start with the basics here's
everything in a hamburger patty from a
uk-5 guys
ground beef
here in the u.s our burger patty is made
up of
ground beef
if you prefer to add cheese to your
burger here's what's in the cheese in
the uk
cheddar cheese water butter cheese milk
proteins whey powder emulsifying salt
trisodium citrate
natural cheese flavoring salt lactic
acid sorbic acid beta-carotene paprika
extract and sunflower lecithin
five guys cheese here in the us is made
up of milk whey milk fat milk protein
concentrate salt calcium phosphate
sodium citrate whey protein concentrate
sodium phosphate sorbic acid
apricola tental what
apocarotinal
aprocatarinol
enzymes vitamin d3 and cheese cultures
the burger buns are also pretty similar
in the uk a burger bun is made with
wheat flour water sugar vegetable fat
milk dry yeast eggs sesame seeds salt
soy flour calcium carbonate and spirit
vinegar the bun in the u.s is made up of
water salt sugar vegetable shortening
milk eggs bleached bread flour yeast and
sesame seeds now you'd think that the
fries would be pretty similar in the two
countries and for the most part you'd be
right in the uk the fries are made of
potatoes peanut oil and salt
the fries of the five guys in the us are
made from potatoes refined peanut oil
and salt now when they say refined
peanut oil apparently the peanut oil in
the uk is not refined here in the us it
is what that means is they do something
with distillation or neutralization i
don't even know but the reason they do
it is to give it a better shelf life and
a more uniform taste this has been the
greasiest food wars ever done so they
are very generous with peanut oil and
the fries and pretty much everything
else
there are a few things to watch out for
on the menu at five guys for example the
pickles in the u.s in the u.s the
pickles contain a food coloring called
yellow 5 or tartrazine if this is added
to foods in the european union they have
to have a warning saying that they might
cause hyperactivity in children
yes our pickles have a bunch of junk in
it so does the relish specifically it is
made up of cucumbers corn syrup water
high fructose corn syrup uh vinegar salt
xanthan gum
0.1 of sodium benzonate as a
preservative calcium chloride alum
natural flavors polysorbate 80
yellow number five and maltol
in our shortest exclusive section yet
here is everything you can only find on
the menu at a uk five guys
and here are all the exclusive five guys
menu items in the u.s let's start with
the burger there's only one option in
the uk that you won't be able to find in
the us and that is hp source i won't go
into too much detail in case joe accuses
me of brits blaming again but for those
who don't know hp source is like the
only customization in the us that you
can't get in the uk is actually
something that everyone in the united
states knows exactly what i'm talking
about and that is a1 steak sauce
it looks a lot like the hp brown sauce
but it is not it doesn't taste anything
like it it is uh the most popular
steak zones
[Music]
is done
i don't know if it even exists outside
of the us
the rest of our exclusive options come
as drinks such as milkshakes we have a
biscuit shake which is flavoured with
biscoff biscuits which are those little
caramel flavored cookies which you get
on the side of a tea or coffee then we
have three dessert shake options which
are milkshakes flavoured with things
which kind of combine to replicate
famous desserts so here we have a
millionaire shortbread milkshake
here we have a banoffee pie milkshake
and here we have a strawberry cheesecake
milkshake now for the last thing the
only shake you can get in the u.s you
can't get in the uk is this is a oreo
listen to me when i say it let me finish
before you start typing and oreo double
stuff milkshake yes you guys have the
oreo shake there i think you also have
an oreo cream shake there too but this
is the only oreo double stuff shake if
you don't have oreo double stuff in the
uk they're what they sound like oreos
with twice as much filling this is the
last thing we're shooting today and i've
been waiting for this
all day
holy this is so good
guys i'm not playing this might have
turned the tides on how i feel about
five guys i'm not kidding this is so
good i'm finishing this i don't care how
sick it makes me i'm drinking it
and last but by no means least in the uk
you can wash your burgers down with
a range of beers
yeah well they don't serve beer at r5
guys but i brought my own
cheers my man
it is very warm
from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between chipotle and the uk and the us
this is food wars
chipotle was by far our girthiest
episode to date i was really struggling
to keep it together in the studio but
our camera person charlie was insisting
that i say that over and over again
this is a uk chicken burrito we've also
got some black beans some white rice
some lettuce cheese sour cream guac as
well inside we're going to measure the
length the
i don't want to say girth oh man
we're going to measure the length the
girth and the weight of this burrito
so our burrito is seven inches long
i have the same burrito harry has right
here well not the same one the same
order i don't know where the burrito
ends in the tin foil begins so i'm kind
of eyeballing it looks to be about uh
between seven and a quarter and seven
and a half inches
a girth of 10 inches
[Music]
it has a gut of
i promise i'm a professional it's
circumference girth really going all the
way around
almost exactly 10 inches burrito is a 10
if you're thinking about making it a tux
and finally it weighs
more than this
this isn't even the big boy hey
told you guys to get a new scale we got
a new scale bear with us
so we're going to weigh this burrito
half at a time to see what the total is
half one 310
and then this one that's okay we'll get
the scraps from the plate
[Music]
so combined the two halves our burrito
weighed 597 grams chipotle's burrito
order wade man that's hefty that is a
hefty boy
in the uk we can also get our burritos
in bowl form
this bowl contains the same ingredients
as our burrito but obviously without the
tortilla wrap let's wear and see what it
measures up to
so this one came out to pretty much
exactly 500 grams which even with the
bowl factored in is like 100 grams less
than the burrito so this here is that
same burrito ingredients in bull form
i'm gonna have to go this way oh wow i'm
really smart wait is it heavier
wow so quickly i'm wrong but there's
more here than it was in the burrito
finally we can get our meals in the form
of a salad
now this has all the same ingredients as
our bowl but without the rice let's
weigh it and see how much difference
that makes
strangely enough this cane's pretty much
exactly 500 grams the same as the
burrito bowl and here is the salad
version of that bowl which was the bowl
version of that burrito
stick it with me so far
being weed
[Music]
i do want to point out this does have
white rice on it i mean salad is boring
and disgusting i would never get one in
the uk you can only get one size of
chips on the side and it's roughly
this many
some of these are a little bit fractured
so i will just try and form whole chips
where i can
like the banksy of tortilla chips thanks
you've done it again
29 30 and a half
at a us chipotle you have two sizes of
chips
the regular
and
the large regular chips first
this could take forever all right
a regular bag is roughly 41 chips now
let's count the large
yes
75.76 nearly double for the large bag of
chips at chipotle very nice in the uk we
only get one size of guac on the side
it's supposed to be four ounces we're
going to measure it to check if that's
the case
ours was just shy of four ounces so
pretty much right the guac in the u.s of
course comes in two sizes as well and
i'm gonna weigh them just to make sure
just to keep them honest i don't know
how much the measuring cup is
so it should be over four ounces of
anything
3.75
that's included in the cup which correct
me if i'm wrong you do not eat
skimping on the guac
don't act like .25 ounces isn't that
much if it's not that much then put it
in there eight 0zers
it's a little over seven
zoom in on that i want to shame these
people shame on you chipotle you're
already charging us extra for it and
you're also just not giving us as much
as we pay for tisk tisk and finally we
have tacos oh hell yeah
when we looked at the menu they were
only available in a portion size of
three in the uk this taco is six inches
in length we got a veggie taco which
includes guac salsa sour cream cheese
fajita vegetables and black beans and as
ways
at a u.s chipotle you can get tacos in
orders of one two or three this guy's
falling apart
it's a six incher and of course
i
did not get
a vegetarian taco this one has meats
aplenty so it has different ingredients
than the one that they weighed making
this weighing completely arbitrary
now this is the biggest burrito you can
get at a uk chipotle we chose chicken as
the base but then we added every other
meat as an add-on and we've also got all
the vegetables and all the sauces they
were a bit reluctant to make this but
eventually they got it done and it seems
to not be leaking so good job guys this
right here is the biggest burrito you
can get at a chipotle in the u.s so big
in fact i named it the big boy got that
fantastic okay what's in it you ask well
it's a carnitas burrito with double
carnitas and i also got double barbacoa
course is double wrapped because it has
guacamole white rice fajita veggies
black beans queso blanco uh mild tomato
i actually got all the salsas
uh sour cream cheese and lettuce this
runs about 18 and 20 cents in the u.s
which is about 13 pounds and
16 shillings this burrito sent me back
16 pounds 75 which is around 22
which is quite expensive you're looking
at kind of two pounds 70 per meat you
add in so honestly if you're looking for
just quantity for lunch it's probably
cheaper to get two single burritos now
it's the same length as the other
burrito coming in at seven inches but
you do get one extra inch of girth and
as we all know
a little again
as we all know electric goes along
now i will measure the length
and
uh thickness of this one almost nine
inches okay it's about
eight
and three-fourths yo
this guy's a lot thicker so that's about
11 and a half inches
of thickness it's much bigger
what about the calories well this is the
most popular burrito from chipotle
contains eight ingredients chicken white
rice black beans sour cream guacamole
cheese fresh tomato salsa and lettuce
this contains 1 320 calories 540 of
which are from fat does contain 2 610
milligrams of sodium which is 113 of
your daily allowance and in the u.s that
same burrito according to chipotle is
the exact same nutrition and calorie
count they use the same small wares and
utensils to make the burritos in the uk
as they do in the u.s so everything
should technically be the same that's
what their pr people told us and hey if
you can't trust uh major conglomerates
pr people who can trust right and if you
got that same order in salad form and
didn't put rice on your salad like a
maniac that would bring this calorie
count down to about 800 and it lowers
the sodium to only 1520 milligrams or 66
of what you should have in the day
chipotle also gives you the option of
having their vinaigrette salad dressing
on the side which adds 220 calories
bumping it back up over a thousand to
one thousand twenty calories and bumping
up the sodium to two thousand three
hundred and twenty seven milligrams or a
hundred and one percent of your daily
basically it's liquid salt
let's put the geez if you choose to get
your burrito in a bowl form that loses
you 320 calories bringing it down to an
even 1 000. now it's only around 40 of
your daily caloric allowance it still
contains
1855 milligrams of sodium however
in the uk a side of chips is 540
calories same with our regular chips
here now if you upgrade to the large
that's going to be 810 calories if you
were to enjoy these with a side of guac
that's an extra 230 calories now if you
wanted to upgrade to the large guac
that's going to be an additional
calories
now chipotle is a brand prides himself
on being quite a healthy option and not
using too many artificial ingredients in
the us they actually make a big deal of
only needing 53 ingredients across the
entire menu however in the uk when we
totaled up all of the ingredients we
found 67 so as you all know if you watch
food wars that's kind of unusual that
there's more things in the us than in
the uk the only ingredient in the u.s
chipotle that gave me a bit of pause was
something called gypsum gypsum's also
known as calcium sulfate hydrate right
okay and chipotle uses that in their
tofu process when they separate the
chunks from the liquid gypsum is also
found in drywall chalk and shampoo of
course it is now does the gypsum stay in
the tofu or is it just used for the
separating purposes i don't care i'm
never getting tofu from chipotle
put the beast back in front of me
let's look at some ingredients for the
flour tortillas in the uk the tortillas
contain fortified wheat flour which is
wheat flour calcium carbonate iron
niacin thiamine water vegetable oils
palm oil rapeseed oil wholemeal flour
salt and raising agents sodium
carbonates diphosphates and malic acid
in the us our flour tortilla only has
four ingredients wheat flour water
canola oil and salt that's it
now i know how joe feels when we film
pretty much all of these episodes
because it's not very nice to have that
many things in your food knowing that
the other side doesn't like why did we
need it but they don't it's weird now
given the fact that we have way more
ingredients in the uk than in the us it
does beg the question as to why the
calorie count for the tortillas is the
same we did reach out to chipotle for an
explanation but unfortunately at the
time of recording they hadn't got bad to
us besides the tortillas a lot of the
other fillings in chipotle have pretty
similar ingredients list in the uk and
the us maybe with some minor differences
in the spices used for example the
chicken in the uk is flavoured with
chicken water chile de arbol and
jalapeno cumin garlic oregano black
pepper sea salt and sunflower oil
whereas our chicken is chicken obviously
water chipotle chili cumin garlic
oregano black pepper salt distilled
vinegar and sunflower oil all words i
can pronounce huzzah our guacamole is
pretty simple it only has six
ingredients avocado red onion jalapeno
citrus juice sea salt flakes and
coriander which is what we call cilantro
and we're definitely right u.s guac is
very similar avocado cilantro or
coriander whatever it's called jalapenos
lemon juice lime juice onions and salt a
serving of white rice in the uk is made
of long grain white rice bay leaf
sunflower oil coriander citrus juice and
sea salt flakes and our white rice in
the u.s contains white rice
bay leaf cilantro lemon juice lime juice
rice bran oil salt and water
finally our monterey jack cheese
contains milk started cheese culture sea
salt flakes and enzymes that are rich
enzymes just enzymes the concept of
enzymes whereas our cheese contains
cheese curds nope cheese cultures milk
salt and vegetable
rennet
rennets
i don't know what that is
here is everything you will only find on
the menu at uk chipotle these are all
the us exclusive items at chipotle now
we only have one exclusive food item on
the menu in the uk and that is the
protein pump bowl
it contains rice a double order of
chicken some lettuce some salsa and some
cheese this first one right here is the
whole 30 bowl for those of you on the
whole30 diet in the middle
cheat sheet number two this is the paleo
bowl and that is a chicken salad with
guacamole uh lettuce fajita veggies
chicken and the medium green salsa
and the last bowl over here is the
protein pumpkin it's got all that stuff
in it this right here
is chipotle's queso cheese not available
in the uk what is the story with this
they figured out a way to make natural
melted cheese and i got to tell you this
stuff
is really good
yeah oh man like their question was
trouble i love that stuff it's really
good a protein that you can get in the
u.s is carne asada you can get that
instead of the steak and cauliflower
rice now there was no cauliflower rice
available at the chipotles you went to
for this video but besides that i went
ahead and made a u.s only chipotle taco
it's just a queso carne asada taco i
figured a burrito of just carne asada
and queso is a little ridiculous this is
like what i would have gotten when i was
in the seventh grade i was a kid just
like melted cheese and meat and nothing
else so here we go
[Music]
i love the queso it's incredible
carnegie style is really good
chipotle also has a children's menu you
can get two tacos or quesadillas i was
surprised to learn with the tacos for
the kids meal you get one meat and two
toppings that yes kids are piggy eaters
only two toppings mom and dad only two
also comes with your choice of chocolate
milk or
apple juice what we lack in exclusive
food options and in fountain drink we
really make up for in cans and bottles
of drink so we'll start with these
things over here which are tensing brand
natural energy drinks it's kind of like
when you want a red bull slash coffee
but you don't want the guilt associated
with it then we have this very
fancifully named fentimans which is kind
of like a sparkling water flavoured with
elderflower personally not a huge fan of
elderflower but some people are and
that's okay
next we have this turmeric and mango
nourish from humble warrior next up
we've got these cans of dash water which
i think they're just water that's kind
of lightly flavoured again we have
orange juice we have berry set go and we
have wonder green if you want something
nice and healthy chipotle's kind of gone
for a fancier vibe with these by the
looks of things these are all kind of
the fancier brands at the end of the day
they are kind of just sodas but they're
ones that are just a bit more up market
than you might normally find a personal
highlight is that chipotle in the uk
sells san pellegrino i don't know if you
guys have this in the us but it's
basically like a brand of sparkling
fruit juices i really love their
lemonade it's like really tangy and
acidic and then finally if you want to
you can finish off your meal with a beer
so it looks like the ones over there in
the uk are pretty much different than
ones we have in the us and this is not
even all of them they have the nantucket
nectars
with juice
see these are is izzy you guys had the
cans of the sand pellegrino water we
just have the bottle of the plain which
i actually prefer yo organic black tea
and right here
the best one
mexican coke it really sucks that
america is so obsessed with high
fructose corn syrup because our coke i
think is similar to mexican coke and
just made with regular sugar
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between pizza hut in the uk and the us
this is food wars
when you order the food have to order
through their app this is such a huge
order ended up with all these like pizza
hut reward points
so on my pizza hut account i'm flush
with pizza on cash and it is amazing
at a pizza hut in the u.s the pizza size
that you want to get is often dictated
by the type of crust you want to get for
instance this right here is the smallest
you can get six inches but you only get
it with the pan crust in the uk our
pizzas come in three sizes firstly we
have this small
okay so they didn't actually have a
small pizza when we went because they
said that no one orders them and if they
do they normally just give them mediums
however a small is supposed to be nine
inches across in the u.s at a pizza hut
the only small pizza you can get is one
with gluten-free crust this one here is
10 inches the next size we have in the
uk is the medium pizza
this one is 11 inches across
the large you can also get in the hand
toss the pan or the thin and crispy
crust this one 14 inches
pizza in the uk also offers an
all-in-one pan box meal where you can
get a large pizza of your choice as well
as two sides and two sauces here in the
u.s you can get two box meal options
this first one is a medium pizza five
bread sticks and some dipping sauce and
then ten cinnamon sticks with dipping
icing and it comes in one box
that really helps when you're eating
this in your car by yourself
[Laughter]
not big enough you say don't worry pizza
hut has got you and the family covered
this is the big dinner box
oh man
look at this dude it's like opening the
suitcase in pulp fiction
this looks
awesome you got two pizzas i got
pepperoni and i got sausage 10 cheese
sticks and you get an option of either
pasta or chicken wings get real get
wings in the uk we got these ones from a
restaurant and they gave us a portion of
six bbq wings not to be outdone we went
ahead and proved a point to no one by
going just a little bit further with our
wing size options you can get six you
can get 12.
you get 18
or 36.
[Music]
lemon pepper nope i don't like that
who's getting the better deal for their
money well in the uk
a large cheese pizza will cost you 15
pounds 99. that's a price of 15 cents
per square inch
the u.s large hand-tossed cheese pizza
is about 13.99 which is about nine cents
per square inch making it about forty
percent cheaper than the same pizza in
the uk
so here we have a large classic crust
cheese pizza
and a large pan crust cheese pizza now
these are the same price and the same
diameter we wanted to find out which one
gives you more pizza for your money so
what we're going to do is try and weigh
equivalent slices and see which one
comes out on top all right
we will
[Music]
weigh a large slice ourselves so pizza
hot large pizzas in the uk are supposed
to be cut into ten slices but they've
actually cut this into eight so what
we're gonna do is try and find a slice
that's the same size for scientific
accuracy let's wear a slice of classic
crust cheese and see what it comes to
now let's weigh the pan crust
so our equivalent size slice of pan
pizza is about 103 grams similarly here
in the u.s this is the hand toss this is
the pan both large cheese pan
so one slice of pan is about 125 grams
hmm
the next one slice is almost the exact
same size
80 grams that's like significantly
less pizza same price
uh yeah stick with the pan look how
thick that is versus this
in the uk a large pan pizza should be
cut to ten slices but ours is eight
assuming it was ten slices each slice
would be 226 calories and that brings
the total for a large pan to
2260 calories in the u.s our pizzas
apparently are all eight slices
regardless of size so one slice of a
large pan pizza pizza is 360 calories
making the entire pie
2
80 calories one of these also contains
99 grams of fat as well as 3 400
milligrams of sodium
this entire pizza also has about 135
grams of fat 54 of those are saturated
fat which i'm certain is the bad fat it
also has
5.31 grams of sodium that in case you
didn't know punching
is 221
of your daily sodium intake don't eat
this all in one day
it's got 100 of your daily flavor in it
what about the most calorific thing on
the menu well in the uk that's a large
stuffed crust pepperoni feast
if it is 10 slices each slice is 292
calories bringing the total to 2920.
one of these pizzas contains more than
double your daily sodium allowance and
more than triple your saturated fat
allowance if you want to have even more
calories in your pizza then you got to
go with the most calorific pizza on the
pizza hut menu and thank you connor that
is of course the meat lovers this entire
thing is
hundred and 3706 calories four hundred
percent of your daily saturated fat four
hundred and it also is three times your
daily sodium uh if i not put a fine
enough point on it don't eat this
here's everything in a pan pizza base
from a uk pizza hut
wheat flour water yeast baker's yeast
rehydrating agent e190 vegetable
rapeseed oil salt premix salt calcium
sulfate emulsifiers e481
e472 e471 flower treatment agent e300
enzyme alpha amylase xylonase glucose
oxidase protease cellulase sugar flour
treatment agent ascorbic acid e300 in
the us our pando has enriched flour
which is bleached wheat flour malted
barley flour niacin
furious sulfate and don't mess with that
sulfate he's pissed diamond mono nitrate
riboflavin folic acid water yeast that
contains two percent or less of salt
soybean oil vital wheat gluten sugar
enzymes absorbing acid sodium sterile
acetite
lack the light
i think it's lactolite now the uk list
might actually look worse but you
shouldn't be too scared of e numbers for
the most part the chemicals actually
exist in the us though as well but are
referred to by different names
for example e481 is just another way of
referring to the sodium steroid lactoly
also the e472e that's found in the uk
dough is otherwise known as datum and
that appears in the u.s hand toss crust
what about the marinara sauce well in
the uk it contains tomatoes citric acid
sugar oregano basil margaram thyme salt
onion powder maltodextrin yeast extract
rapeseed oil gua gum garlic powder and
silicon dioxide whereas our sauce
contains tomato puree which is water and
tomato paste maltodextrin salt spices
garlic powder tomato fibers olive oil
canola oil citric acid and natural
flavor so it sounds like it's pretty
much the same thing how about the cheese
in the uk we refer to our cheese as
mozzarella and it contains the following
mozzarella cheese salt lactic cultures
and potato starch it's actually pretty
short compared to the first two in the
u.s the pizza refers to as cheese as
cheese which contains mozzarella cheese
pasteurized milk cheese cultures salt
enzymes modified food starch sugar cane
fiber potassium chloride
excuse me uh
natural flavors absorbic acid
there is one thing to look out for on
the menu if you're in the us and you get
a salad the croutons contain
azodicarbonamide or ada this is a
substance that's usually used to make
vinyl foam plastics which form things
like yoga mats it's actually been banned
from using food in the uk since the
1990s
so this is my comment on that yoga mat
thing
it's always something even we're trying
to be healthy a salad has yoga matte
plastic and it's ridiculous like why do
our croutons have plastic in them just
get regular croutons without plastic it
doesn't make any
sense pictures of the bob dude that's
really good
[Music]
here is everything you can only find on
the menu at a uk pizza hut i've got
quite a few excuses and this are all the
exclusives you can only get at a us
pizza hut so i'm not sure if it's like
this in the u.s but in the uk pizza huts
operations are kind of split into two
halves you have a bunch of restaurants
where you will go and have a sit-down
meal and then you also have a bunch of
carry-out locations which just do
delivery orders the menus are actually
slightly different depending on where
you get your food from the brown ones
are actually from a sit-down restaurant
and the red ones are from a takeaway
restaurant we wanted to get a selection
of both to see all of the foods you can
get from uk pizza hut for what harry was
talking about before
places for carryout versus delivery only
i have no idea i just went on the
website and ordered it and this showed
up so let's start with the exclusive
pizzas so across these few pizzas we
have pretty much all of the exclusive
customizations available in the uk we'll
start with some of the doughs on the
left we have our gluten-free option i
think there actually is one of these in
the u.s but could be fun to compare ours
looks pretty standard from the top but
my personal favorite is here which is
the cheesy bites crust so instead of
just a standard crust they get twists of
dough and fill them with cheese and then
layer those around the outside here we
have a
sprinkled kind of like herby cheesy
situation on the crust i've never had
this one before i think it's quite new
but it looks and smells pretty good and
then finally we have a vegan stuffed
crust option which is great because you
shouldn't be robbed of extra cheese just
for being vegan
right in the center here is the u.s
exclusive pizza hut pizza
it's shaped like a heart and it has all
the ingredients you only get in the u.s
went with the creamy garlic parmesan
base as a sauce the crust is a flavored
crust and i went with the hut favorite i
have no idea what that is and exclusive
meats i had put on here was italian
sausage meatballs and pork also has
banana peppers
shaped like a heart why it's all year
round and not just on valentine's day is
beyond me but apparently you can do this
nothing says romance like a heart-shaped
pizza how do you cut that thing though
it seems like getting even slices out of
that would be an absolute nightmare
look what i brought all right so i guess
i will just do
right
[Music]
yeah no i hate that
now as it's becoming traditional on food
wars what we have here is a uk only
pizza this is a pizza with the cheesy
bites crust
with vegan pepper phoney caramelized
onions and rockets on it
it's actually not bad i'm gonna try
cheesy bite as well because i think
that's part of the experience
[Music]
i think this is the first uk only
creation we've made that i can actually
endorse it's actually pretty good
the vegan pepperoni i've gotta say is
actually good
the texture is pretty much there it's
like quite salty a little bit of spice
to it
and the cheesy bites like it does make
it a little bit harder to hold because
it's like
what are you supposed to hold on to but
they themselves are actually really
tasty
so yeah thumbs up for the uk only
pizza hut's most infamous menu items is
their take on the calzone aka the
pizzone p apostrophe z-o-n-e i've had a
pizzone before they're actually really
good i was
really bummed to find out that where we
are filming in this part of the united
states the los angeles california area
unfortunately the bazone is not
available went on the internet and sure
enough the zone is available at least in
st louis and at least in cincinnati so
if anyone watching the united states
would like to ship me a pizzone from
their zone plentiful part of the united
states please do um
i don't know how i'll get you high
address
now as you can see we have a bunch of
exclusive sides in the uk i'm not
entirely sure what all of these are
because some of them look very similar
so we'll have a run through and i'll try
and point out the ones i can identify so
at the back here we've got some potato
wedges i'm never really sure why
restaurants offer potato wedges because
to me they're just worse than fries in
pretty much every metric then we've got
a bunch of different chicken options
we've got these kind of like chicken
strip things here we've got these kind
of like spicy looking nugget things
we've got these herbie looking nugget
things and then we've got some plain
looking nugget things
as well as these like i think southern
fried bites apologies to actual southern
americans because i'm sure they are an
abomination here in america we have
something called wing street one i
understand wing street was a separate
business or separate restaurant chain
that is owned by the same brand and
therefore you can get wing street wings
when you order from pizza hut anyway we
have a bunch of different sauce options
like we have a honey barbecue buffalo
which can be mild or medium or burning
hot
garlic parmesan and of course
what was this one that i hate
lemon pepper which i don't like you can
also get a hawaiian teriyaki a spicy
garlic a cajun style dry rub or you just
get these bad boys naked
worst time to burp there why do all the
wing street containers are like death
stars that seems like a sub-optimal way
to transport your food it's like a half
ball and then the lid is like another
ball sauce tuck
sauce talk you can also get exclusive
sauces on the side for instance blue
cheese
get yourself some ranch
uh cup of marinara and the buffalo
sauces of various temperatures honey
barbecue sauce sides of sauces we got
you covered uh outside of that we've got
some
nachos we've also got these like cheesy
bites which are just triangles of cheese
that get breaded and deep fried because
i guess cholesterol isn't a thing
anymore
we've also got some onion rings we've
got some corn cobs
we have cheesy garlic bread regular
garlic bread and we also have
mac and cheese but it turns out
you can also do that with mac and cheese
uh also wing street fries uh just orders
of fries that looks like you can get
pretty much the same
flavors as the wings when they toss them
in the same sauce use your lemon pepper
oh that's good
i don't like lemon pepper i'm finding
out something i thought every pizza hut
around the world had apparently not are
breadsticks looks like five sticks joey
we went over this in the papa john's
episode that is not a breadstick and you
can also get cheesy bread which is like
breadsticks but they bake them with the
cheese on top of them this is the
chicken alfredo
is this just how they packed it there's
a buffalo sauce and a barbecue sauce in
here why uh these guys right here i'm
probably gonna pronounce them wrong okay
papa's like tater tots
yeah we also have a bunch of exclusive
desserts at uk pizza huts if you're
eating a restaurant you have a few
options including one of these brownie
slices this is actually a vegan vanilla
cheesecake which looks and smells really
good i gotta say
and then you have a cookie dough thing
which usually comes with a little scoop
of ice cream as well and the desserts
huh we're almost done people
uh this thing right in front of me are
cinnabun mini buns this is the ultimate
hershey's chocolate chip cookie
if you're getting delivery from pizza in
the uk there are also some exclusive
options this is another sort of giant
cookie dough situation bites of ben and
jerry's cookie dough again it's usually
served frozen but they have now
unfortunately defrosted and then they
have some branded ice creams as well we
got their triple chocolate brownie last
and not least
cinnamon sticks with a lot of icing you
know i gotta do it
[Music]
from calorie council portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between shake shack in the uk and the us
this is food wars
now i love this episode because for the
first time i got to work with a dog
she's called mabel she is owned by our
office manager megan and she was amazing
in the uk burgers come in two sizes
single and double
and in the u.s our shake shack burgers
also come in single or double we're
gonna weigh the double shack burger to
find out if it's actually the same size
in the uk as it is in the us
oh man
ours weighs a lot less significantly
less what's up with that shake shack
in the uk we can only get fries in one
size and this is it in the u.s we also
have only one size of fries
what i meant to say was let's see how
much they weigh
so our portion of fries came to around
188 grams what
this 188 ours is like a little over 100
like when i say 105 i might be generous
it's a lot less so far the fries and the
burger have been significantly
smaller than the uk
i thought we were the ones with the big
portions
drinks from a uk shake shack come in two
sizes regular and large the us we also
have only two fountain drink sizes
regular and large we're going to measure
them to find out how much is actually in
these
so a regular drink from a uk shake shack
has about 400 milliliters in it
why should in a big one first
little over 16 ounces
it fits that's good
it has gone slightly over the scales i'm
gonna in my infinite wisdom assume
that's around 600 milliliters give or
take a few
so that's 16.
jump to the little guy
six and a half
16 plus six is 24
right 22.
and we'll give it a half so 22 and a
half fluid ounces for the large
milkshakes in the uk only come in one
size we're not sure what it is so again
we're going to measure it in the u.s our
shakes also come in one size
i mean this thing might be to the line
16 ounces
uh-oh
got some bad news connor
looks like it's a little under 16 ounces
hmm
in the uk you can also get beer from
shakeshack this normally comes in a
serving of one pint however
unfortunately due to the reduced menu
from the pandemic we couldn't get one
today
the shake shacks in the u.s are still
serving beer so the ones we got to go
were cans got the 12 ounce and the 16
ounce i'm gonna assume this is the same
size cup that this is a pint
fun pipe fact for you uh our pints in
the uk are actually bigger than your
pints in the us we use imperial
measurements and our pints are around 19
ounces whereas yours are 16. if all
pints are magically half to size i'm
just drinking twice as much i've never
stopped to think how many fluid ounces
in a beer it's like
get me out of here what about hot dogs
well a hot dog from a uk shake shack is
six and a half inches long
what in the heck
is this
they cut the hot dog in half
cursed image
am i getting punked here
first five guys and now shake shack
i i get it i'm fighting a losing battle
i guess normal hot dogs yeah i mean five
guys reached out to me i haven't heard
back from them though at the recording
of this shake shack you're on the list
now too you're on the list now too i
want to know what's going on these hot
dogs i did not bring the tape measure
but the good people at apple
have an app
that measures stuff for us this shoot of
course is sponsored by apple
all right
so i'm going to measure this hot dog
this is actually working
six and a half inches
thank you apple
and it weighs
126 grand
it looks like it's like exactly on 125.
and last but by no means least shake
shack in the uk and the us are both
known for being quite dog friendly and
as such you can get
dog treats
these are red velvet dog treats and they
come in packs of five
they were saying there's a red velvet i
don't know what art is supposed to be oh
it's got the shake shack logo on you see
that
oh i don't like how they smell
i'll be a little bit like a communion
wafer
i'm not getting red velvet
now we're gonna get the expert opinion
on dog treats
hey mabel hi yeah there's chicks on the
floor wait
this is mabel the dog and she's going to
taste test the treats for us called
maple
yum
this is mabel the dog and we're going to
get her thoughts on the dog treats from
shake shack
what do you think mabel wow
not bad not bad
do you taste red velvet
no
i don't know if you taste the red velvet
but she seems to be enjoying it so good
job guys
bring me the dogs
hey paul
you think
you want a big one
how is it how is it how is that
need salt
i mean you see that you see what i
talked about before about like these
like they're like almost like those
matzah crackers you get those really
like tasteless ones that
like your mom gets because she doesn't
want you eating all that salt or
whatever i don't know if this would be
my top favorite go-to dog treats but
in a pinch
yeah
so what have you been up to during
quarantine
[Music]
unfortunately shake shack in the uk
doesn't disclose any of its nutritional
information
however we can get nutritional
information in the u.s so let's start
with the calories in a standard meal if
you get the double shack burger and the
fries and a chocolate shake you're
looking at
2010 calories which is just a little bit
over your entire daily recommended
allowance so just eat this every day
once what if you're in the mood for
something even unhealthier well this
right here is the double smoke shack
burger and it's the most calorific
standard burger at shake shack clocks in
at 870 calories just the burger this is
also the menu item with the highest fat
content in the us one of these contains
57 grams of fat which is 73 of your
daily allowance it's also the saltiest
thing on the menu a double smoke shack
contains a huge three thousand thirty
milligrams of sodium that's over a
hundred and thirty percent of your daily
allowance shake shack is also unique in
its approach to regional specialties
with pretty much every location having
an exclusive burger or custard however
some of these are way less healthy than
others
for example the least healthy burger
found at any shake shack menu is a
lockhart link burger this is exclusive
only to austin texas so listen up all
you relocating tech bros and joe rogan
this is a burger with jalapeno cheese
shake sauce pickles and a sausage link
from chris market in you guessed it
lockhart if you get one of these as a
triple it contains over half of your
daily calories
more than a hundred percent of your
daily fat and almost double your daily
sodium but the most calorific item found
on any shake shack menu actually isn't a
burger it's something called the double
down fries they are found only in vegas
double down got it okay and they contain
1910 calories those fries alone are 95
of your daily allowance i mean give me a
break you're in vegas like you care at
all right
give me the fries i just lost my fortune
unfortunately shake shack in the uk also
doesn't disclose its ingredients a bit
shady what's going on there guys give us
some info to work with and that's also
the case here in the us we've reached
out to them to see if they'd make an
exception but they could not help us out
what we can get is a list of allergens
and it has a couple of fun things to
know for example there is a significant
risk of there being traces of seafood in
our banoffee concrete and there are also
sulfites in our chicken bites and in the
shack sauce we may or may not also have
shellfish in our shroom burger shack
burger shack stack and smoke shack so
there's no potential seafood the uk
equivalents of these burgers have no
idea why there might be shellfish in
ours here in the us i i couldn't even
guess why but in better news all our
shake shacks us beef is freshly ground
100
angus beef that's free from hormones and
antibiotics and the buns are non-gmo
here is everything you can only find on
the menu at a uk shake shack
here are all the us exclusive shake
shack items you cannot get in the uk
let's start with the burgers
here we have the shackmeister burger now
this is a double version it comes with
beef fatties cheese shack sauce and then
some crispy l-marinated shallots yes we
pronounce it shallots that's the correct
way to pronounce it you guys are wrong
for a limited time in the uk we can also
get a spicy version of the chicken
sandwich which is the hot chicken
sandwich
this comes in hot or extra hot if you're
feeling bold
we would usually be able to get some
more exclusive hot dog options including
a chat cargo dog which i think you might
be able to get as like a secret menu
item in the us and also a shackmeister
sausage which is kind of like a hot dog
but with a cumberland style sausage
which is something that's kind of
popular here in the uk but unfortunately
due to the reduced pandemic menu we
weren't able to get these
harry you know my feelings about the hot
dogs you know my feelings about hot dogs
in general and i will say as someone who
was born and raised in chicago i would
love to try the chicago hot dog at the
uk shake shack so when i come to visit
that'll be our first stop now on top of
the limited edition hot chicken burger
we can also currently get some hot
chicken bites as well as some spicy
fries so the only two sandwiches that we
really get our hands on that are
exclusive to the us and not in the uk
are the grilled cheese and the korean
chicken sandwich okay
first things first this grilled cheese
look at this thing did you is did you
sit on this too
this is ridiculous
i wouldn't pay a dollar for this it
looks like they took two buns put cheese
in it and then i don't know ran over
with a steamroller or something why is
this so thin
what does look actually bomb
is this the korean chicken sandwich
yo
yes
yes to this oh my goodness
with the kimchi i'm telling you i'm
telling you
you want that i also think the shake
shack in the u.s has you can't get in
the uk are the breakfast sandwiches
we're shooting this like at 4 p.m so
surprise to no one the breakfast
sandwiches were not available but
usually if you get there i'm assuming
before 10 30 or 11 you get a bacon egg
and cheese sausage egg and cheese and
just some egg and cheese check them out
i have no idea if they taste good or not
also a thing you can get in the u.s
is
cheesy bacon fries but this has been
sitting for more than a minute
oh my god i think it's gonna come out
like a disc
oh god i want to make this perfectly
clear this is not an indictment of
shake shack quality this has been
sitting for at least two hours i mean
it's bacon and cheese on fries
even if that consistency is still pretty
good i mentioned this before
but there's like all these different
regional things throughout the country
so i don't know if this whole korean
sandwich in korean
chicken bites
is just in this area but i think
i'm about to lose my mind
no
you want this oh yes
yes to these yes to these
now much like the way u.s shake shacks
have exclusive burgers and custards some
of the uk branches also have exclusive
options themselves the one we went to
had a dessert option called the union
shack which is a really terrible pun on
the union jack which is our flag
now it's effectively just a chocolate
custard with some chocolate from british
chocolatiers however unfortunately due
to the pandemic reduced menu couldn't
get that either and of course it
wouldn't be a shake shack episode unless
we talked about the shakes now the uk
wide exclusive flavors include coffee
and caramel and then the branch we
visited also had a cinnamon toast shake
which i'm really intrigued by
mixy mixy
it's not bad very sweet and quite
cinnamony as you would expect
it's so many different menu items across
regions it'd be impossible for us to
cover all the things that every specific
shake check in the us alone so given the
ones that we had that we went to the
three exclusive shakes we have are
brownie batter hot cocoa vanilla black
sugar
cookies and cream once again
end of the day end of the shoot
i'm gonna put me into a coma after this
yeah that's pretty good
like it has a little bit of like an
extra chocolateness to it
it's not too sweet
the caramel flavor is there but it isn't
like chemically
tasting that's the one to beat
cookies and cream baby
cookies and cream
whoop
here we go
i can't decide if that one's better
that's so good from calorie count to
portion sizes we want to find out all
the differences between dunkin donuts
haha it's me
okay i'll do it for real
[Music]
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between dunkin donuts in the uk and the
us
this is food wars
oh yeah this episode grubhub canceled my
order an hour before it's supposed to be
delivered for the shoot so i had to
frantically run to a dunkin donuts and
order it and i put us behind the chute
and i was totally frazzled i don't know
if it comes across in the episode but if
you watch when you watch the dunkin
donuts episode notice that i am
incredibly aggravated
dunkin donuts in the u.s you get your
donuts in three different sizes i guess
one donut
half a dozen donuts nice
and of course everyone's favorite
dozen donuts
in the uk our donuts also come in three
quantities and shockingly it's the same
as in the states
you can get one donut a half dozen
donuts
or you can be the life of the party
with the full dozen
and it's food wars so you know
we're weighing a doughnut now let's see
how much a glazed doughnut weighs in the
uk
[Music]
our glaze doughnut came to pretty much
exactly 50 grams so it looks like the
states are getting a better deal
at a us dunkin donuts you can get your
munchkins in four different units of
munchkin
[Music]
five munchkins
dude
ten munchkins
not enough
kick it up to 25 munchkins yeah and if
that isn't enough you can go all the way
to 50 munchkins 50 of these things wow
look at the size of this it's a lot of
munchkins in the uk we also have four
units of munchkin starting with
four
from there we move upwards
to
12 munchkins the next size up from 12
is in a box and the box contains
24 munchkins and finally
our biggest size of munchkins in the uk
it's 50.
that might not make too much sense to
compare just one munchkin in the uk and
the us because i'm sure they're all
slightly different shapes and sizes
however what we could do is measure 24
munchkins here and 24 machines there and
hope that it provides a kind of overview
of the average weight that's not about
right
sounds like science to me let's do it
all right this is 25 so i'm going to
take one out oh
can i do it without spinning
let's go
oh god
how is that so good
okay munchkin challenge number one uh
how many munchkins can i fit in my mouth
at one time
without dying
[Music]
i'm not ready
can you hurry this up man we got other
stuff
[Music]
done yes seven you were roughly right
but i feel like i started cheated
because i almost died
in the u.s dunkin donuts our hot coffees
come in four sizes
small in the uk our hot coffees come in
two sizes regular and large
large
and
extra large
the dunkin donuts us website says that
their large hot coffee is 20 ounces got
a measuring cup here let's find out if
that is true now
full disclosure and the car head over
here
had a little bit of a spillage
so i'm gonna give this one we'll say a
two ounce leeway should be 20 ounces
might be 18.
okay that's 16.
four more ounces
give me a break
that's maybe an ounce 16 plus one i
think is still 17. there is no way
there is
this much of coffee in my car seat let's
generously add 2 16 17 18 19. i don't
want to be that generous wait a second i
got an idea 20 ounces so that means i
need four in here correct
okay
that's 20 ounces
i'm gonna settle this right now
okay there's 16 in a cup
plus four you know what's about to
happen you ready
[Music]
come on now now that all seems very
dramatic so i'm also going to measure
our large coffee
not black coffee did i get that with
milk i'm so stupid i just remembered i
put milk in the lodge so we're going to
measure anyway and see what happens
[Music]
looks pretty much exactly 16 ounces
iced coffees in the uk also come in two
sizes regular and large at a dunkin
donuts in the us we have three iced
coffee sizes
small
yeah mediums and
the large
i don't need two ounces of coffee that's
just too much
32 ounces do i have enough for 32 ounces
of 16 and this is
eight no i don't we're also gonna
measure our large iced coffee to see
what it comes to
so a large iced coffee in the uk came to
18 ounces since i don't have another 16
ounce cup
i will use this one
right on the 16th
okay
that's 116 ounce
oh geez this is exactly 16 ounces here
was this the large
this should be 16 more fluid ounces
[Music]
shameful
absolutely
shameful
there definitely was not this much space
left in the cup 27.5 fluid ounces
in your 32 ounce large iced coffee
it's still almost to the i mean our pa
just pointed out that maybe the density
is different right when you put exactly
the most frozen ice maybe
we'll
let's ask someone who's a scientist
not a scientist but that won't change
everything and you guys are still kind
of getting a bit short-changed it's just
because the density of the solid or the
liquid might change the actual amount of
liquid in there is still going to be the
same so it should all balance itself out
eventually at the u.s dunkin donuts the
largest single food item you can get is
this two dozen donuts and the largest
drink you can get is
a box of joe look at this i think that's
about a hundred fluid ounces of coffee
i've always wanted to do this it's like
really hot in here okay
[Music]
just set this down in my seat and be
like
this is my coffee
all right write my name right on it's
right there joe do not touch
what is it oh yeah
mine baby mine
oh man i've already drink way too much
coffee
[Laughter]
now the biggest thing on the menu in the
uk is the dunkin feast this is two dozen
donuts 50 munchkins and two boxes of joe
all for a price of 80 pounds now
unfortunately when we went in today they
didn't have any boxes of joe available
however one of them is supposed to be
100 fluid ounces of coffee which is far
too much coffee
this here is a us glaze dunkin donut
donut it is roughly 360 calories has 22
grams of fat 10 of those are saturated
420 milligrams of sodium 39 carbs and 18
grams of sugar
and in the uk the same donut has 230
calories 13 grams of fat 230 milligrams
of sodium 25 grams of carbs and 10 grams
of sugar so by my calculations the u.s
glazed donut is 56.5 percent higher in
calories 69.2 percent higher in fat and
80 percent higher in sugar i get a burp
sorry let's talk about another donut the
boston cream donut i don't know why it's
shaped like a heart i'm assuming because
it's valentine's we're shooting this in
february normally it's a circle anyway
this donut has
270 calories 11 grams of fats 18 grams
of sugar the uk version of the boston
cream contains 280 calories 15 grams of
fat 17 grams of sugar so that has more
calories and fat a large iced coffee
with cream and sugar in the u.s has
roughly 260 uh
hang on
back to life baby
a large iced coffee at a dunkin donuts
in the u.s has 260 calories 18 grams of
fat and 37 grams of carbs that seems
like a lot doesn't it
in the uk a large dunking coffee with
cream and sugar comes to 190 calories
with 9.1 grams of fat and 38.4 grams of
carbs
if we break it down by fluid ounce it
turns out the u.s is higher in every
metric except carbs just look at all
that data think about adding a flavor
pump to your coffee in the u.s and the
uk you can get vanilla caramel hazelnut
flavors on average in the u.s though
when you add those pumps you are adding
165 calories 38 grams of carbs and 37
more grams of sugar all of our
information from the uk for this episode
was taken from not dunkin donuts uk but
other
nutrition sites and food bloggers and
whatever assuming that the iced coffee
in the us and dunkin donuts are the same
not sure if it is they didn't tell us
thanks a lot dunkin donuts uk but
assuming it is the same to get this
large iced coffee with cream and sugar
and these two donuts we talked about
earlier total it is
890 calories which is 35.6
of your daily intake and in the uk a
large iced coffee with cream and sugar a
glazed donut and a boston cream donut
comes to 700 calories or 28 of your
daily allowance
what about munchkins in the u.s one
glazed munchkin is 60 calories it's 3
grams of fat 60 milligrams of sodium 7
grams of carbs and 3 grams of sugar
now unfortunately duncan in the uk does
not release any of its ingredients
information we did reach out to see if
they make an exception but unfortunately
at the time of shooting this they had
not us dunkin donuts website does have a
majority of its nutritional info on the
site let me read you some hits right now
okay first the coffee hot or cold it's
100
brewed arabica coffee fantastic now if
you want to add cream and sugar to your
coffee like a 16 year old influencer now
you've added milk cream to sodium
phosphate as a stabilizer sodium citrate
as a stabilizer and sugar
of the many flavor shots you can add to
the coffee in the us i picked the
caramel one because it's also available
in the uk assuming that it is the same
in the us and the uk in the us the
caramel shots are made up of sweetened
condensed non-fat milk which is not fat
milk and sugar high fructose corn syrup
and sugar water and brown sugar so three
different various sugar substances
fantastic caramel color potassium
sorbate as a preservative natural
flavors and salt
a glazed donut at a u.s dunkin donuts is
made up of enriched wheat flour which is
flour malted barley
okay
niacin reduced iron thiamine mono
nitrate riboflavin folic acid all right
uh water palm oil yeast donut
concentrates brackets which is soy flour
salt leavings
sodium acid
pyrophosphate
baking soda
wheat starch whey a milk derivative
non-fat dry milk
gum blend which is a cellulose gum guar
gum acadia gum carrageenan
and xanthan gum
a lot of gum do you scroll please
sodium
cassonate which is a milk derivative
sodium sterol acetate less
lactolate and it contains two percent or
less of soybean oil soy lecithin whole
egg natural flavors turmeric extract for
color enzymes and nettle extract for
color yeast dextrose soybean oil and
mono and diglycerides okay that's the
dough now for the glaze we ain't even
done yet scroll up please the glaze of a
glazed donut has sugar water
maltodextrin and contains two percent or
less of cornstarch mono and diglycerides
citric acid agar cellulose gum potassium
sorbate as a preservative and of course
artificial flavors it's a lot of stuff
so what's in the boston cream donut you
ask all right the dough is the same as
the glazed dough but the bavarian cream
filling is water sugar modified food
starch corn syrup palm oil and it
contains two percent or less of
sucrose esters
natural and artificial flavors oh my god
glucano delta
lacto i mean they're just making fun of
me at this point
glucano delta
lactone sounds like a font
salt potassium sorbate and sodium
benzonates for preservatives and agar
and beta carotene for color and of
course don't forget about the chocolate
icing which is sugar water cocoa high
fructose corn syrup soybean oil corn
starch corn syrup maltodextrin it
contains two percent or less of dextrose
palm oil salt potassium sorbate and
sodium proponier preservatives soy
lecithin artificial flavors and agar and
you know what i'm not going through
every donut
[Music]
here's everything exclusive to the u.s
at dunkin donuts here is everything you
will only find on the menu at a uk
dunkin donuts i'm not sure if they have
any bagels at the uk dunkin donuts but
in the u.s you can get cinnamon raisin
you can get
sesame everything oh you can also get of
course english muffins
an english muffin how come england
doesn't have the english muffins
makes you wonder
makes you wonder here are all the
exclusive donuts you can only find in
the uk there are a lot of them and i've
forgotten all of their names so i'm just
going to make up names for them as i go
and then we can put the actual names off
on screen for you
let's start with this one this is sonic
the hedgehog it's very very bright if
you see something that's this color in
nature just do not eat it this one i
believe is mr happy little smiley face
it's kind of cute or sinister perhaps
depending on your interpretation of
things
it's worth noting that some of these are
only here because we're filming this in
the run-up to valentine's day so they've
got a bit of a love theme going on right
now this one is uh love dust
flat line pretty in pink
heart bypass
love prison this is like jail cell bars
this one is
keith
this one i'm jazzed about this is the
apple crumble donut now i know american
pie is a very american thing whereas in
the uk we quite like a crumble instead
of pastry we have a kind of like flour
and butter crumble mix on top so many
different donuts than the us not in the
uk i didn't want to do every single
donut that's different but three that i
feel are like kind of like the hits that
i would figure were everywhere but
apparently not in the uk are an
old-fashioned this one right
apple fritter hang on
this is so good in the coffee roll look
at the size of this coffee roll man it's
like a spare tire
oh yeah a coffee cake muffin
also in the u.s and get corn muffins and
some dunkin donuts not the one that i
went to unfortunately
breakfast sandwiches dunkin donuts in
the u.s has so many different varieties
of sandwiches
far too many to mention in this i got as
many as i could find
so one of these is a turkey sausage egg
and cheese
the other one is
a beyond
meat breakfast sandwich these all look
the same
veggie
egg white omelet sandwich on the protein
thins the power breakfast sandwich i
don't know
this one what is this this one's got
like some bacon and stuff on it an egg
white with bacon sandwich on a croissant
here's just a few other ones that are
available in the us and not in the uk
that i couldn't get my hands on limited
menu the belgian waffle breakfast
sandwich
uh maple sugar bacon
big and toasty
angus steak sandwich
they also have chicken bacon sandwiches
a chicken biscuit which i would love to
have had wasn't available and of course
their exclusive grilled cheese also they
have snacking bacon and those dunkin
bowls i can't believe they didn't have
like i got those just recently along
with bagels you can also get white
cheddar bagel twists and finally we have
a few other items that you will only
find in the uk we'll start with these
two cookies this one is a chocolate
chunk cookie
and this one is a salted caramel cookie
this one looks like aggressively salty
there's big chunks of sand not sand
salt
sand would be a gross cookie then we
have two exclusive hot coffee options
which are the cortado and the flat white
a cortado is a foamed milk and espresso
combination and a flat white is a
steamed milk and espresso combination
then we have a couple of exclusive cold
options as well this one is a mango cool
latte which is like a mango flavored
kind of blended ice drink it looks
pretty good can you imagine that being
quite refreshing on a summer's day
and then finally we have this which is a
shaken lemonade uh it kind of just looks
like water now i'm not sure if that's
just because it's been sat here for a
while under the lights but it's quite
impressive to watch the lady make it in
the shop she was actually going at it
with a cocktail shaker and it was bit of
fun the drinks
so many different drinks that you can
get the u.s you can't get in the uk i'll
just start down here
first one iced cappuccino am i taking a
sip of everything
ice cappuccino
yeah that's all right frozen chocolate
iced americano
peach passion fruit refresher
a strawberry dragon fruit refresher the
only hot one we have here is a matcha
latte iced matcha latte ooh we're
talking about the
culattas yo
kulatas yeah
strawberry kulana
[Music]
ooh
a little tart i like that
conserving straws
yeah that oh that's the best one blue
raspberry blue
raspberry colada i love those on my high
horse about how sweet these beverages
are and how bad it is for him culatta's
pretty nice
a green culatta
that's something matcha i don't know
what that is there's matcha in it and
last but not least at least i don't
think okay
this is a
milk colored culada
can't i can't imagine this being any
good
whoa that's actually pretty good
yeah it's vanilla this is too much of
any of these but i would have a coolatta
if it came in like three ounces just
like a shot
from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between krispy kreme in the uk and the
us this is food wars
this was my favorite episode to shoot i
ate so many donuts it was awesome and i
also didn't get nearly as sick as i
thought i was going to so that was nice
in the uk we can get donuts in four
portion sizes
as a single donut
as a three
a dozen
or
maybe the life of the party
with a double dozen
in the u.s you can get your donuts in
single
two if you get it with a coffee combo
three pack
dozen look at these beauties or
two dozen
now technically the double dozen isn't
the biggest thing on the uk menu krispy
kreme in the uk will cater for events
like your weddings or your parties and
they can do something called a donut
wall which contains 216 donuts hanging
on pegs on a wall that's 18 dozen krispy
kreme will also make you something
called the donut tower it looks almost
like a wedding cake and is made of
around 216 donuts you got to give them a
heads up though because i went to the
krispy kreme today and asked for one and
they said no also in the usa krispy
kreme you can get mini donuts in four or
20. i have to know
i'm in trouble i don't know i'm gonna
make it through the shoot counter these
are so good
this right here is a standard usa krispy
kreme classic glazed donut
i want to bite into you so bad
but before that let's weigh it now we're
gonna weigh a glazed doughnut in the uk
to see what it comes to
they're so light
in the uk our hot coffee sizes are
regular and large us krispy kreme you
can get your coffee in three sizes small
medium and large and if you're really
thirsty
get yourself a brew box
nice
a large hot coffee in the uk is supposed
to be 16 ounces so we're gonna measure
that to find out if that's true and to
make sure that this reading is
absolutely accurate got a big boy
[Music]
okay
krispy kreme in the u.s can get your
iced coffees in two sizes medium and
large iced coffees in the uk also come
in two sizes regular and large they use
the same cups as the hot coffees they
ditch the plastic ones apparently to cut
down the plastic waste now we're going
to measure our iced coffee black
oh
definitely more coffee now besides donut
walls the biggest thing on the uk menu
is this the sharer bundle it's four
dozen donuts and it comes to 41 pounds
and 95 pence this here is the largest
single menu item you can get at a us
krispy kreme it is the meat in greet two
dozen assorted donuts and a brew box all
for
42.95 let's look at nutrition this is a
classic ring glazed donut from krispy
kreme and it contains
200 calories 8.3 grams of fat 12.6 grams
of sugar and 96 milligrams of sodium
that same donut in the u.s is 190
calories 11 grams of fat 10 grams of
sugar and 85 milligrams of sodium ours
is less with everything except fat
few people can stop after just one donut
so if you decide to have three of these
the calories go up now you're looking at
600 calories which is 30 percent of your
daily allowance and in the us these
three donuts are slightly less in
calories it's 570 over here but look at
how much sugar these three donuts had
it's almost three fourths what you
should be having in one day speaking
honestly though if i have these it's not
going to have a salad for lunch getting
a dozen donuts for you and your friends
or just yourself
that would put you at 2400 calories
and in the u.s our dozen comes to
2280 calories i would hope you wouldn't
eat all 12 of these by yourself but if
you do i guess that's all the calories
you're going to need for the day i can
eat 12 of these easy another popular
donut of krispy kreme is the chocolate
glaze just ignore the sprinkles on ours
because we didn't have any plain ones
now this one is 237 calories and also
beats the classic glazed in pretty much
every other metric probably because of
the chocolate frosting our us chocolate
glaze is
240 calories so looks like the chocolate
glaze helped put us over the top what
if you want even more calories in your
donuts how about the uk's chocolate iced
with custard now this one is 289
calories and ours is 300 calories 300
just this one doughnuts
definitely
in the uk the most calorific donor is
this one the lotus biscott donut it's
396 calories
the most calorific donut you can get at
a krispy kreme at least in america is
something called the chocolate chip
cookie dough doughnut made with chips
ahoy cookies and it is 400 calories they
weren't available where we went
the second most calorific doughnut you
can get at a krispy kreme is the oreo
cookies and cream donut that's 390
calories
also couldn't get it
the third
most calorific doughnut
you can get at a krispy kreme in the
united states is the double dark
chocolate donut 370 calories
no and the fourth most calorific
doughnut you can get at a u.s krispy
kreme is the cake batter donut 360
calories
we got it
this is a nice looking this is like what
i mean this is
sprinkles it's colorful
oh man i'm fading fast
i shouldn't i'm going to drink all those
coffees
what about the drinks well this is a
large mocha with 2 milk and in the uk it
contains 247 calories 16.3 grams of fat
12 grams of sugar and 80 milligrams of
sodium in the us our large mocha is 480
calories one gram of sugar and
260 milligrams of sodium come here you
salty mocha dog
whoa this is good i'm surprised i
thought i wasn't going to like it i
normally don't get like chocolatey
drinks if you get this as an iced coffee
it contains 280 calories 12 grams of
sugar and 40 mg of sodium do you want to
get it iced now the calories are 420 2
grams of sugar and 190 milligrams of
sodium since the uk and u.s sizes are
different we've calculated it per fluid
ounce and we found some pretty shocking
differences from the uk to the us
there's a 55.5 calorie increase and
ninety three point three percent sugar
decrease and a one hundred and sixty
percent sodium increase
[Music]
do you having way too many donuts on
this thing dude i'm losing losing my
mind
and in the u.s our donut is made up of
enriched wheat flour which is wheat
flour niacin reduced iron thiamine mono
nitrate riboflavin folic acid i'm
getting better at this
water palm oil soybean oil sugar it
contains less than two percent of each
of the following yeast soy lecithin
hydrogenated soybean oil salt mono and
diglycerides weak gluten calcium sulfate
monocalcium
phosphate yes and bht ah yes our old
friend bht aka butylheidylated
hydroxytulene
it is banned in the european union the
international agency for research on
cancer suggests might i say strongly
suggest there is sufficient evidence
that bht causes tumor growth in lab
animals also according to webmd bht is
also used to treat genital herpes
[Music]
all right dried milk powder egg yolks
yolks yolks egg yolks cellulose gum
calcium proponent to maintain freshness
ammonium sulfate sorbic acid dicalcium
phosphate sorbitan monosaturate
monocerotates tocopherols
i scratch that i'm going to tough time
on this one try calcium phosphates
dymonium
phosphate and that last guy
dymonium phosphate aka dap not the
sequel to wap it is also used as a
fertilizer and as a fire retardant so
when we have the next wildfire outbreaks
in the state because it definitely will
happen we're going to start dropping
krispy kremes on those wildfires
solved
[Music]
in the uk a glazed donut is made of the
following wheat flour wheat flour
calcium carbonate iron niacin thiamine
water dextrose palm oil yeast salt wheat
gluten emulsifiers mono and diglycerides
sorbitan monostearate raising agents
monocalcium phosphate dicalcium
phosphate sugar dried egg yolk powder
skimmed milk powder preservative calcium
propionate stabilizer carboxymethyl
cellulose firming agent calcium sulfate
flavoring acidity regulators ammonium
sulfate diamonium phosphate flour
treatment agent ascorbic acid enzyme
amylase anti-kicking agent tricalcium
phosphate
oh i'm not done
nope there's more
that was the donut now we're going to
talk about what's in the glaze sugar
water
and a glycerine it's a lot of
ingredients
for a donut one thing worth pointing out
is the differences in the sprinkles
between the uk and the us three of the
colorings used in the us are actually
subject to restrictions in the european
union and if they're included in foods
they must bear a warning that they may
cause hyperactivity in children not here
though baby and not here
blue one isn't actually on this list but
it's also very hard to come by in the uk
it was famously removed from smarties in
the uk several years ago and it took
them three years to find a natural
alternative to the blue color which
ended up being spirulina
[Music]
here is everything you can only find on
the menu at a uk krispy kreme and these
are all the things you can get at a us
krispy kreme let's start with some
donuts the first one we'll look at is
this one the lotus biscoff now lotus
biscoffs are those little biscuits which
you usually get on the side of a cup of
coffee it's like a caramel flavored
crunchy cookie and we're kind of
obsessed with them in the uk this one
comes with some crumbled up biscoff on
the top now i think the icing also has
biscoff in it and there's also some
biscoff injected inside as well next up
we have this one which is a chocolates
dream cake caramel iced ring donut nutty
filled berry ring donut the purple love
hearts donut now this one's been
produced in collaboration with
lovehearts the candy as you can see by
the
very cute phrase on top this is a very
thing we just got one that says omg next
up we have the caramel sensation nutty
chocolata now it's actually a
heart-shaped donut with some chocolate
icing on top and importantly it's full
of nutella
it's a little bit underwhelming i wanted
more nutella to come out now
pretty good
and these are all the exclusive items
you can get at a us krispy kreme okay so
the us krispy kreme has
so many exclusive usa only donuts but
they're not available on every krispy
kreme so the one we specifically went to
had about a dozen of those donuts a
original filled chocolate cream so you
can see in the little white spot there
that that is where they put the cream in
there pretty sure that's an apple
fritter that's a birthday cake i only
saw before
chocolate icing
filled with custard
yeah that's definitely a custard one
you can see the yellow in there
i'm gonna assume this is maybe the uh
glazed sour cream cake sugared ring and
cinnamon sugared ring
see there's a claire right here
new york city cheesecake glazed
raspberry filled
oh god
oh
[Music]
there's nothing much stuff in here
oh it's so good
i'm gonna be so sick and i don't care
also the us krishna cream you can get
these donut holes they put them in these
cups that might be reusable
the uk does not have these as before
mentioned
minis
it's usually 20 but the crew got to them
too fast i couldn't stop them couldn't
stop them
now on top of the donuts themselves the
uk also has exclusive ways of presenting
the donuts for example here we have a
birthday box and you can also get a
donut with a customized message printed
on it unfortunately we didn't give them
enough warning so maybe if the editor
can just add one here that would be
great
the krispy kreme in the us has a lot of
varieties of hot and cold drinks you can
get your lattes in a version of vanilla
caramel or white chocolate and then the
ice drinks
same rules as before
everything has a vanilla
white chocolate and caramel version this
right here is the malibu dream it is a
strawberry banana and vanilla shake
tastes okay we actually have a few more
things i forgot
oh almost forgot get bottle drinks to go
krispy kreme in the uk also offers a
range of exclusive shakes we have four
of them here we have the oreo shake a
strawberry and cream shake the lotus
biscott shake and then this one is a
chocolate cream shake back at it again
with the biscott like what's the deal
with that why is everyone's obsessed
with this stuff i don't get it
i'm just gonna say i don't like biscoff
and i'm mad that they put it in so many
things on their menu i'm gonna try the
oreo one because even though it's sat
under studio lights for several hours it
still looks and smells pretty good
that's very sweet they're pretty good we
can also get some exclusive ice drink
options in the uk including a pink
lemonade an original lemonade a frozen
mango and a coffee chiller although
unfortunately the ice machine was broken
when we went so we couldn't get them
today
from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between wingstop in the uk and the us
this is food wars
[Music]
wingstop was the most expensive in the
usa food order wise food wars episode we
spent over 500
on wingstop food that is an insane
amount of money and please stop doing
that future
[Music]
in the uk we can get wing portions in
four sizes
eight wings
10 wings
12 wings
or a flavor craver wing platter
which comes with 24 wings and three dips
us wingstop you can get your wings in
not enough you say i agree wingstop also
does wings in orders of
[Music]
50
75
and of course
100
chicken wings i'm in heaven right now
bury me in these wings
i'm going in
ah
i'm gonna do better but we gotta move on
shawn evans i'm coming for you buddy
so the portion sizes might be pretty
different but what about the wings
themselves we're going to weigh 10 plain
wings in the uk and do the same in the
us to see how they match up
so 10 plain wings in the uk came to 290
grams which is an average of 29 grams
per wing
oh
way higher dude
360 grams i needed my calculator app to
determine what 360 divided by 10 is and
it is in fact 36 grams wow so our
average is 36 grams per wing here in the
u.s what about chicken tenders well in
the uk those come in two portion sizes
as a portion of three
as a portion of five
at a wing step in the u.s you can get
your chicken tenders in orders of four
seven fifteen twenty and thirty
yes
i don't know what
maniac
is at a wing stop and gets chicken
tenders instead of
wings i get if you like take your like
10 year old there
let's weigh 5 chicken tenders here in
the u.s
so five plane tenders in the uk weighs
230 grams 200 what
way over 300 on this one we're over 300
and they try to pass this off as a
tender bigger chunks of meat over here
in the u.s bigger tender chunks of meats
what about a side of fries well in the
uk these come in two sizes
regular
and large
and in the u.s our wingstop fries also
come in two sizes regular
and
large how those look
we're gonna wear them both to see what
they come
that's to a good look for fries
how do i get this back in
yep
also a brick also a brick
and the large portion came to 255 grams
our regular is bigger than your large uk
okay
oh lots of fry
400 grams
fountain drinks in the uk come in one
size it's 22 ounces but unfortunately we
weren't able to get one today
wingstop in the us you could found
drinks in two sizes
20 ounce
and
32 ounce the wingstop we went to did not
have any 32 ounce cups
dips in the uk only come in one size and
it's regular we're going to weigh a cup
of ranch to see how much we get
dips in the u.s come in two sizes
regular in this absurd tub look at this
first we're gonna weigh this the
regular
size now the big boy i i couldn't even
guess how much this container weighs
before i do this
closer to 300 this is heavy
this is like a half a bottle of ranch
[Laughter]
bro
it is
440. 440 grams of ranch
so fun fact about me i've never actually
had raj before this is not a common
dressing in the uk
it's just not really on menus we prefer
like a garlic mayonnaise or a ketchup
so i'm about to try it my first ever
brunch see how it goes
hmm
okay okay
i don't know if wingstop ranch differs
to the classic you might find in the
states but it's nice if you want like a
kind of
cooling thing
with a similar effect to mayo in that
regard but like a little bit more tang a
bit more seasoning
yeah you guys are doing it well
the biggest thing on the menu in the uk
is this the flavor craver wing platter
you get 24 wings three dips and no other
sides all for a price of 22 pounds 50.
biggest single menu item at the wing
stop in the u.s is this the 100 wing
party pack okay obviously you start with
a hundred wings you can get up to six
different flavors i just got the same
one four orders of large fries
four orders of veggie sticks and eight
dips this is supposed to feed 13 people
or like you and three of your friends
you can get boneless or bone-in wings if
you go boneless it's
94.39 and if you go all bone-in wings
it's 104
and 19 cents i gotta say i'm generally a
drums guy over a flat skype i think it's
just the shape is great it's just like a
meat lollipop and also it feels like you
get more meat on there than you do on a
flat no harry no drums are not good
flats are way better you can pull out
both bones you get all the meat off of
it for the drum it's way harder to get
the meat off don't be deceived by that
shape it's less meat flats
flats
have a flat head
[Music]
here is everything you will only find on
the menu at a uk wing stop and here are
all the exclusive items you can get at a
us wing stop
we'll start with the chicken there's
actually one flavor of wing that we can
get that you guys can't which is this
one it's brazilian citrus pepper
i'm gonna try the brazilian citrus
pepper using my patented
wing eating technique get one of the
bones up and then little meat lollipop
nice little freshness from the citrus
kick from the pepper
not bad so for exclusive wing flavors
you can get these two the bayou barbecue
and the lemon hot we can also get any
wingstop flavor on the side i don't know
if you can get that in the uk another
thing you can do at the us wing stop is
you can customize your fries and you can
get regular or extra seasoning so i got
an extra seasoning of a seasoning you
guys don't have in the uk which is the
garlic parmesan look at the seasoning on
this i mean they just dusted this thing
right you know exactly what i'm going
down
yeah
yeah
these are louisiana voodoo fries
they are topped with a cheese sauce
ranch and cajun seasoning our exclusive
fry option is this
sweet potato fries these come in sizes
of regular or large and you can also get
them in the same seasonings as the
regular fries in my opinion you guys
aren't missing out on much with these i
just always think that sweet potato
fries are worse than regular fries they
always cost more they always come out
soggy it's just not worth it just stay
with the regular
outside of meat and potato you can also
get cajun fried corn am i saying that
right it's fried
you can also get
freshly baked rolls
bread baby
bread
we also have one other exclusive side
which is this it's a honey mustard slaw
we can also get booze from our wing
stops
this comes in the form of two types of
beer and usually we'll be able to get
two types of wine however due to a
reduced menu currently they're not
serving them the three drink options you
can get in the u.s are oddly enough
sweetened and unsweetened tea i don't
know why we have tea in the uk does not
and also you can get this
52 fluid ounce
simply lemonade and finally in the uk
you can finish off your meal with some
churros these come in portions of either
six or ten you have two crumb options
including oreo or lotus biscoff and then
you can choose from one of two sauces
either a sweet milk or some dulce de
leche caramel
what about desserts here's one you get
in the u.s and not in the uk at a wing
stop the triple chocolate chunk brownie
they say that in the right order
fantastic
i'm not gonna do something really stupid
which is attempt to eat the hottest wing
on the wingstop menu which is the atomic
wing these come with gloves
just to avoid getting it on your skin
and then getting it in your eyes i'm not
good with spice one thing to note
ah man i don't really want to do this
but hey
for the content cheers
yep that's immediate
[Music]
oh man
[Music]
deep breath sorry deep breaths
terry's doing it i'm doing it too
this is a harvest
i'm not tough guy with the heat this is
nothing hot
[Music]
yeah
it sounds hot
[Music]
yeah i'm starting to feel it
ah
my tongue's kind of starting to hurt
that's what they do on the uh and how
one's one
[Music]
unfortunately wingstop doesn't disclose
any of its nutritional information in
the uk
they do disclose the nutritional
information in the u.s however and there
are some pretty interesting takeaways
okay let's start with this the classic
meal for one an eight piece combo i got
four hot wings four lemon pepper regular
fry dip regular coke this meal contains
a total of
1595 calories along with a lot of your
daily fat and sodium allowance
interestingly if you get the same meal
but boneless wings instead the calories
go up to one thousand seven hundred and
eleven roughly a seven percent increase
even more interestingly the sodium in
the meal rockets up to five thousand two
hundred and fifty eight milligrams which
is two hundred and twenty eight percent
of your daily allowance so it looks like
boneless wings are way saltier than bone
in wings but they do contain slightly
less fat
what's the most calorific wing at
wingstop in the u.s that would be the
boneless garlic parmesan wing which
clocks in at 112 calories for just one
the saltiest wing on the menu is the
boneless original hot wing now it's less
calorific than the garlic parmesan but
just five of these is your entire daily
sodium allowance
the tenders at wingstop are as you might
expect more calorific than the ones the
most calorific flavor in the u.s garlic
parmesan wherever i heard that before
that's not the saltiest tender that
crown goes to the cajun spice tender
775 milligrams of sodium just three of
these is your entire daily allowance
i didn't come here to not eat chicken
tenders
[Music]
what about the dips well the least
healthy dip on the menu is this it's
honey mustard just a regular portion of
this in the u.s contains 367 calories 33
grams of fat 5 grams of saturated fat
682 milligrams of sodium and a slightly
alarming 17 grams of sugar as for the
rest of the menu you really want to
watch out for the fries the most
calorific single menu item on a wing
stop menu is a large portion of the
louisiana voodoo fries this serving
alone
910 calories which is almost half of
your daily allowance if you're looking
to cut down on sodium you might want to
avoid the buffalo ranch fries they're
slightly less calorific from the
louisiana voodoo fries however they
contain 2 80 milligrams of sodium that's
125 percent of your entire daily
allowance
in summary wing stop maybe not the
healthiest fast food chain if you're
looking to cut back on your sodium
definitely skip the boneless wings and
maybe stick to regular fries and not the
ones with these gross toppings
[Music]
now sadly along with the nutrition
wingstop uk also doesn't disclose its
ingredients wingstop also does not
disclose its ingredients in the us
so what do we know about what goes into
the chicken well for starters in the uk
the chicken is not organic and not free
range all the chicken they use in the uk
is also halal which means it's suitable
for muslim people to eat
now it is unclear if the u.s chickens
are free-range or organic all wing stops
say that they expect their chicken
supplier to conform with usda fda state
and local regulations however they do
not specify a grading so for all we know
it could be grade c chicken which can be
misshapen poorly fleshed and jesus and
with no limit on the size number of
areas or intensity of discolorations and
flesh bruises wow i wish i knew that a
few minutes ago
in better news the fact that they refer
to their tenders as tenders legally
means that they have to at least be made
of whole cuts of chicken breast and
might be actual chicken tenderloins
which are in the inner pectoral muscles
of the chicken breast and that's pretty
much all we can glean from the
information that's publicly available
why are you so sneaky wingstop is it
because you know we'll eat it regardless
correct
[Music]
you